Ups, ich habe mich gemutet.
Ah, excellent.
Ich wundere mich schon.
Oh, ne, ich glaube ich habe einen Wackelkontakt. Kann das sein?
Oh.
Monka. Monark S.
Wackelkontakt.
Wackelkontakt in meinem Kack-Verlängerungskabel.
Was ist denn da los?
Das geht aber nicht.
Verlängerungskabel brauche ich.
Dankeschön für den Sub, Martin.
Huge Big Brain Sub.
Big Brain.
Das Verlängerungskabel kackt wirklich ab.
Man weiß es nicht.
Ah.
Achso, stimmt. Wollte ich noch machen, ja.
Du hast recht. Ich habe nämlich das Repo angelegt.
Ich habe nämlich das Repo angelegt.
Und dann habe ich nichts reingepusht.
Stimmt. Guck mal da.
Warum genau jemand...
Warum hat das jemand geforkt?
Da ist nichts drin.
Sascha, warum hast du das geforkt?
Ja, mache ich.
Habe ich ganz vergessen.
Habe ich komplett vergessen.
Ja, habe ich wirklich ernsthaft komplett vergessen.
Ähm.
Leute, ich habe nur Stream angemacht,
weil ich so lange nicht mehr gestreamt habe.
Ich habe nämlich heute mal geguckt
und habe festgestellt, es ist schon wieder 4 Tage.
Ob ich euch jetzt Mist erzähle?
Aber ich bilde mir ein.
Das war, was ich gesehen habe.
4 Tage.
Ja, ja.
Und mittlerweile sieht übrigens auch Twitch anders aus.
Das ist VollmonKS.
Da findest du nichts hier.
Da findest du nichts.
Wie kommst du denn...
Wie kommt man jetzt auf die Videos?
Irgendwie so, ne?
Ah, excellent.
Verstehe.
Und wozu hat das jetzt hier so einen hässlichen...
So einen hässlichen Rand, Alter?
Das ist ja Cancer-Layout.
Was ist das denn?
Der sieht da mega hässlich aus, Alter.
Ja, ne, ich wusste, dass die...
Ich hatte es ja vorher auch schon gefunden.
Ne, guck mal hier.
4 Tage, sage ich doch.
Deswegen, ähm...
Valorant-Key, nö.
Gibt's die jetzt, oder was?
Gibt's die jetzt?
Kriegt jetzt jeder eine Valorant-Key?
Ich hab mir das überlegt, ob ich mir eine Valorant-Key besorgen soll oder nicht.
Aber ich hab...
Ich warte noch mal ein bisschen.
Ach, das ist Mario-Kart-Musik, ja.
Ein bisschen laut.
Das stell ich grad fest.
Warum hab ich denn die IHK auf?
Oh, die Emote sind doch ein bisschen klein.
Besser.
Ähm, ja.
Ich push da nachher was rein.
Genau, nachdem ich festgestellt hab,
der letzte Stream ist, wie gesagt,
jetzt schon wieder
4 Tage her,
bin ich extra mal online gekommen.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute Abend gar nicht online kommen,
sondern weiter ein bisschen Modern Warfare spielen.
Ich bin ja die letzten 3 Tage
übelst am Modern Warfare grinden.
Allerdings zum größten Teil
Warzone
und ein bisschen 2&2.
Aber,
allerdings, muss ich sagen,
der normale Multiplayer ist richtig scheiße.
Ich hab jetzt ja ein paar Mal normalen Multiplayer gespielt
zum Waffen anlocken
und das Einzige, was in diesem Spiel
halbwegs erträglich ist,
sind die Spielmodi, die noch schlechter sind.
Ist schwierig zu erklären, aber
normalerweise hab ich ja in Call of Duty
am liebsten Free-for-All und ein bisschen
vielleicht ein bisschen Team-Best-Match-Dominär.
Am liebsten hab ich eigentlich Free-for-All gespielt.
So, allerdings ist
jeder normale Spielmodus
Modern Warfare
so extrem krass passives
Ecken abamen,
dass du dir fast schon vorkommst,
als bist du irgendwie in CS.
Und deswegen spiele ich am liebsten,
um Waffen zu anlocken,
einfach stinknormales
ähm, wie heißt
diese Playlist?
Shipment und Rust
und
Shoothouse und sowas.
Das ist zwar eigentlich
richtiger Müll,
aber es ist deutlich erträglicher
als der normale Multiplayer,
einfach weil es total hirnlos
äh, Respawn, Ballern,
Respawn, Respawn, Ballern, Ballern,
Respawn ist.
Der normale Multiplayer regt auf.
Ha!
Genau.
So sieht's aus.
Ne, der normale Multiplayer ist wirklich
Müll, finde ich.
So, und was allerdings Spaß macht,
was ich nicht erwartet hätte, ist
2-on-2 macht Spaß,
wir haben gestern irgendwie 12 Runden oder so gespielt,
nicht einmal verloren,
was allerdings an meinen Mitspielern lag,
nicht an mir.
Und Warzone macht auch Spaß.
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass mir Solo Warzone
nicht so wahnsinnig Spaß macht.
Solo Warzone krankt
so ein bisschen da dran,
wie der normale,
wie der normale Multiplayer,
Autsch,
bevor man Arm verdreht irgendwie,
krankt so ein bisschen wie der normale Multiplayer,
ähm,
dass es halt Extremes rumgeschimmelt ist.
Und ich hab halt keinen Bock,
20 Minuten zu spielen
und 5 Gegner zu sehen.
Man kann natürlich auch krass auf Kills spielen,
das geht auch.
Allerdings ist es dann halt
sehr random, ne.
Mal machst du 11 Kills in,
in irgendwie 5 Minuten oder 3 Minuten oder so,
und mal bist du direkt down.
Also,
es ist schwierig, also,
am meisten Bock macht Warzone mit mehreren Leuten.
Ich bräuchte irgendeinen,
der mich mal ein bisschen coacht in dem Game.
Oh, Scheiß.
Also mal,
ein bisschen mal obsorft,
guckt, wie ich spiel,
und mir dann ein paar Tipps gibt.
Ähm,
weil so
holt man schneller auf,
dass man jetzt einfach 2 Monate,
Monate hinten dran ist mit Game üben.
Fragt den Patrick.
Der krasse Warzone-Owner mit 6 Kills, oder?
Ja, 11 Kills war jetzt so ein Beispiel.
Das hat,
das war, glaub ich, das Game,
das Game mit den höchsten Kills,
das war, glaub ich, das Game, das Game mit den höchsten Kills,
was ich bisher hatte,
ähm,
war,
11 Kills,
auf,
äh, gut, die Map ist immer,
ist die Map immer die gleiche, oder?
Warzone und Warzone ist immer die gleiche Map, oder?
ähm,
da bin ich in der Mitte abgesprungen,
auf dem Teil der Map,
der aussieht wie die Groundwar Map.
Es ist schwierig, Warzone, äh,
Call of Duty Modern Warfare Maps zu beschreiben,
weil die sind,
in dem Game, sehen die alle irgendwie so hingeklatscht aus.
weil die sind, in dem Game, sehen die alle irgendwie so hingeklatscht aus.
Und,
in diesen, in diesen Industriehäusern,
da ging's halt übelst ab.
äh, ich hab, ich hab übrigens Subs übersehen, glaub ich!
Dom PC, 5 Monate,
excellent, Subscription, huge!
dom pc 5 Monate, excellent, Subscription, huge!
Dankeschön für den Sub, und
wen haben wir denn hier noch? Den Arrow,
OD, Twitch Prime,
Wahnsinn, ey.
Big Brain Subscribers, wieder.
Big Brain 360 Subscribers!
Ähm,
ähm, Matt,
Davon lernt man aber nix.
Er schreibt gerade, er schreibt hier gerade, ähm, hab ich das eigentlich hier mitgeloggt?
Ne, er schreibt gerade, ich soll ein Video hochladen, dann kommen ja relativ schnell die Experten, die mir sagen, was ich falsch mache.
Das ist ungefähr wie, also wenn man auf YouTube Kommentare hört, was man in seinem Gameplay verbessern soll,
dann ist das ungefähr so, wie wenn man sich, ähm, bei MMOs an Reddit orientiert.
Das ist so, das gibt so ein paar Dinger, die gehen immer nach hinten los.
Die YouTube Comments sind einfach nur Bullshit von Leuten, die selbst keine Ahnung haben, in 90% der Fälle.
Und, ähm, Leute, die MMOs spielen und auf Reddit rumspammen dazu, was OP ist und was schlecht ist und sonst was, sacken einfach nur in dem Game meistens.
Was ist eigentlich gerade so für Trends auf GitHub?
Zum Beispiel, es gibt, es gibt ein richtig gutes Beispiel, warum Reddit sackt.
Also in dem Fall, warum, warum Reddit voller Noobs ist.
Ich hab die letzte Season Path of Exile gespielt.
Als Ultra-Noob.
Ich hab das Spiel gespielt, ein bisschen, als es rausgekommen ist, auch mit dem Friseur zusammen.
Und danach hab ich ewig nicht mehr gespielt.
So.
Letzte Season hab ich mir ein paar Bilder durchgelesen.
Hab relativ schnell ein Bild identifiziert, der absolut.
Noob-Style für jeden Volldepp zu spielen ist.
Und hab angefangen.
Und ich hab nebenbei immer ein bisschen Forum und Reddit gelesen.
Und ich dachte am Anfang, ich brauch ein Bild, was maximal so 5, 6 Chaos-Orbs kostet.
Weil man ein Bild, was viel kostet, ist kein richtiges Bild und so.
Totaler Schwachsinn.
Reddit, Alter.
Reddit.
Feels Reddit, man.
Totaler Bullshit.
Ähm.
Ich hab dann gespielt.
Und ich hatte, glaube ich, schon ein paar Bilder.
Und ich hab dann gespielt.
Und als ich im Endgame angekommen bin, 20 Chaos-Orbs oder so.
Es ist total hängengeblieben.
Reddit.
Reddit ist einfach nur voller Kack-Loops.
Real Reno sagt, hey, du bist doch dieser Commentary-Typ, den ich vor ein paar Jahren mal gefeiert hab.
Das kann ich, das weiß ich nicht, ob ich das bin.
Möglich wär's.
Also wenn du den hier meinst.
Wenn du den hier meinst.
Ähm.
Dann bin ich das nicht.
Ich hör mich nur ähnlich an.
Den Keks hab ich nur geklaut, ja.
Na, ich war halt ziemlicher Max-Fanboy.
Und dann hab ich den Keks leicht abgeändert, auch auf Twitch genommen.
So.
Also, was trendet denn heute auf GitHub?
Was gibt's denn da Schönes?
Mr. Wipp, warum hast du denn...
Warum hast du denn dieses Video jetzt rausgesucht?
Das ist ja uralt.
Guck mal, was er hier für ein Video rausgefischt hat.
Ja, ja, Achtung.
Achtung.
Servus, Leute.
Kaboom hier.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Ja.
2011.
Lass das gemeinsam...
Nein, das gucken wir nicht gemeinsam.
Das ist...
Eine...
Es ist...
ZWEI STUNDEN!
What the fuck?
Was haben wir denn bitte schon zwei Stunden gelabert, ey?
1.200 Comments, alter.
Ich muss euch was ekliges erzählen, Leute.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich nicht gut...
Ob es irgendwie ein bisschen übel ist, oder ob das nur so eingebildet ist.
Und zwar...
Ich hab vorhin...
Bevor ich Stream angemacht hab, hab ich in der Küche unten gesessen, hab mir Brötchen gefuttert.
Und, ähm, hab halt ein Glas Wasser eingeschreckt, ein Glas Wasser ausgetrunken.
Ich trink...
Also...
Ich trink immer alles auf einmal.
Also, ich...
Ich schütt...
Ich mach das immer auf einmal.
Also, ich... Ich schütt... Ich mach das immer auf einmal.
Ich mach das Glas von unten bis oben voll.
Und dann mach ich...
Das ganze Glas weg.
Also, selten mal mit Absätze zwischendurch.
So, und...
Während ich das so leer trinke,
Na, dann hebt man das Glas ja immer weiter nach oben.
Und während ich das so leer trinke,
kann man ja so durch das Glas...
durchschauen.
Und ich trink das so, und ich denke mir auf der Rückseite...
Vom Glas hängt was.
Trink ich weiter, trink ich weiter...
Und sehe, hä?
Warum hängt auf diesem komischen...
Stück Dreck oder so unten am Glas?
Warum sind da Blasen drauf?
Trink ich weiter und stell fest...
Äh, der Dreck ist innen im Glas drinne.
Da hab ich halt...
Hab ich halt abgesetzt...
Und da war unten...
Unten am Boden vom Glas...
War so ein Daumennagel...
Großer Stück...
Schleim.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das sah übelst eklig aus.
Hahaha.
Ey.
Und da hab ich natürlich nicht weiter...
gleich weggeschwitzt, aber es war schon...
eklig, ja.
Und ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich da im Glas drinne hab.
Aber ich hab meinen Mundschutz auf.
Okay.
Leute,
genauso eklig, wie der Chat jetzt tut,
war das auch.
Deswegen trinkt man aus der Flasche.
Das geht nicht.
Ich kann nicht...
Ich kann nicht aus der...
Flasche trinken.
Geht nicht. Also geht wirklich nicht, weil...
Ich hab keine Flasche.
Ich hab keine Flaschen im eigentlichen Sinn.
Ich hab sowas hier.
Sodaclub Sprudler.
Sowas da hab ich.
Allerdings mit so...
Mit solchen...
Solche Plastikflaschen hier.
Da kann man nicht raustrinken aus den Flaschen.
Aus dem Wasserhahn.
Nee.
Wasser...
Ich mag kein stilles Wasser.
Das muss gesprudelt sein.
Und mittlerweile...
Ich hab das ja schon, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre oder so.
Wir haben das Lager, dieses Zeug schon hier.
Und...
Also solche Geräte.
Und ich hab mich so
an den Geschmack gewöhnt,
von unserem Leitungswasser hier,
dass mir jedes andere Wasser gar nicht mehr schmeckt.
Und...
Das ekligste Wasser finde ich ist...
Warte mal, ist das Hassia?
Das grüne?
Ist das grüne Wasser Hassia?
Nee.
Äh, nee, Bad...
Bad...
...Filbler...
...Quelle oder so gibt's da noch?
Das da.
Ur...Quelle.
Ey, das schmeckt total eklig.
Ach, der Name.
Dann lieber noch
die Rheinfelsquelle.
Falls die noch einer auf YouTube kennt.
Das schmeckt eklig.
Öh.
Schmeckt so, als wäre da irgendwie Salz reingemischt
oder irgendwas.
Hanauer Leitungswasser, beste.
Sei euch.
Monkabeh.
Monark S.
Das Wasser in Deutschland ist so gut,
kann man immer trinken. Das stimmt.
Wie heißt dieses Wasser nochmal?
Was die...
Destillieren
und danach wieder
Salz und Zeugs zusetzen, dass es immer
gleich schmeckt?
Da gibt's irgend so ein Markenwasser.
Was die quasi, wo die Wasser
destillieren und danach wieder umwandeln.
Überkinger?
Was zum geier ist Überkinger?
Hört sich an wie irgendeine spanische
Pornseite.
Nee, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Was? Fiji?
Hab ich auch noch nie gehört.
Ist das das?
Das könnte das sein, ja.
Ja, ich glaub das ist das.
Ich glaub das ist das.
Das könnte das wirklich sein.
Nee, oder?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist es nicht.
Nein.
Es könnte Apollinaris sein, was ich meine.
Ich bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Total bescheuert.
Der Kommentator ist da.
Robi.
Also, was trendet denn aktuell gerade so auf GitHub?
Zeig mal her.
Deno. Ja, das wollten wir uns auch mal im Stream angucken.
Ich hab die Existenzberechtigung
noch nicht so ganz verstanden,
ehrlich gesagt, von Deno.
Weil das wichtigste an JavaScript
sind eigentlich die 30 Milliarden
Pakete, die es gibt.
Wenn ich die alle nicht verwenden kann,
warum soll ich dann Deno verwenden?
Das versteh ich noch nicht.
Naja, gut.
Dann trendet noch irgendwelche Corona-Simulationen.
Ey, ich sag ja in letzter Zeit wenig.
Über Corona und sonst was.
Ich rante immer zwei Minuten und so.
Aber ich muss jetzt mal was loswerden.
Weil aktuell,
wenn man auf Twitter guckt,
schauen wir mal.
Twitter-Trends.
Ach nee.
Ah nee, es trendet gerade irgendwelche
AfD-Geschichte.
Okay, das kommt auch zu Abwechslung immer mal wieder.
Genau.
Also es trendet ja total oft
auf Twitter gerade wieder irgendwelche
Verschwörungsgeschichten.
Und dann Leute,
die
sich lächerlich machen über
Verschwörungsleute.
Dann gibt es welche, die sagen, wir sind besorgt
wegen Corona-Maßnahmen.
Da gibt es Leute, die posten dann ihr
Covid-Idioten.
Ihr seid ja alle total bescheuert.
Also quasi
jeder versucht mal wieder die Welt zu
verbessern auf Twitter.
Und
was dabei total
untergeht ist,
ähm,
ich muss mal kurz überlegen,
wie ich das am besten ausdrücke.
Also was da komplett untergeht ist,
dass es durchaus
von allen
beteiligten Parteien,
also Parteien meine ich jetzt
Leute, unterschiedliche
Gruppierungen, die an diesen
Sachen da beteiligt sind, dass alle
die ein oder anderen
sinnvollen Punkte haben.
Allerdings,
sobald du zum Beispiel
auf Twitter schreibst, ähm,
was ist denn gerade angesagt,
ja hier, äh, Freiheit wird
wegen Corona eingeschränkt, hast du gleich
die Leute, die dann übelst drauf abgehen,
Max, du willst, dass Leute verrecken.
Oder wenn du umgedreht schreibst,
oh, ich glaube, ähm,
ich hab ja gepostet,
man kann den Leuten schlicht und ergreifend
nicht trauen, sich an Maßnahmen zu halten,
deswegen wird es wahrscheinlich wieder hochgehen.
Da kamen auch schon die Ersten, die gesagt haben,
alles nix gebracht, Shutdown umsonst,
ganze Maßnahmen umsonst, wir werden
verarscht, also
sprich, egal was du sagst,
die andere Seite springt immer komplett drauf.
Was halt total untergeht ist,
dass alle Seiten,
wenn man mal genau guckt,
schon sinnvolle Punkte haben.
Und ein Punkt, wo ich da an
sich bin, dass der viel zu wenig
angesprochen wird, ist,
da wirst du aber auch schon wieder gesteinigt auf
Twitter, wenn du das schreibst, ne.
Ähm,
ich sehe die Einschränkungen
der Grundrechte in Deutschland
auch kritisch, aber
ich sag nicht, dass es unsinnig
ist. Man muss sich mal
überlegen, ähm,
wie man, also man könnte das viel
besser an die Leute kommunizieren,
warum man Sachen
macht, und das vermisse ich ein bisschen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt sagt,
Leute, bleiben wir mal am ganz einfachen
Beispiel, wenn man dann sagt, Leute,
alle Eisdielen müssen dicht machen, weil
die, weil Corona.
So.
Dann ist das erstmal,
man stellt die Leute vor vollendete
Tatsachen und sagt, weil Corona.
Die Sache ist bloß die, weil Corona ist
keine sinnvolle Begründung.
Ähm, man müsste,
und das würde auch den ganzen
Verschwörungstheorien vorbeugen,
und das würde auch den, das würde
sehr vielen Sachen vorbeugen,
wenn man die Maßnahmen, die man trifft,
ordentlich erklärt.
Also sprich, wenn man sagt,
ja, wir haben jetzt
ABC-Maßnahmen beschlossen,
und wir haben diese Maßnahmen
beschlossen aus diesen und diesen Gründen,
wir haben uns überlegt,
was man sonst noch machen kann,
uns ist bewusst, dass man
zum Beispiel, ähm,
hier schon stark in die Grundrechte
eingreift, aber wir sind
zu dem Schluss gekommen, das geht nicht anders,
weil so und so,
wir haben uns die und die Punkte überlegt, aber
die funktionieren aus diesen Gründen nicht,
deswegen müssen wir es so machen.
So. Und wenn man das
machen würde, dann würden das
auch vielen Sachen vorbeugen.
Glaubst du, dass die Leute so eine lange
Aufmerksamkeit sparen haben? Na, wenn die Leute
so doof sind, mal zwei Minuten sich das anzugucken,
dann haben sie halt gelitten. Aber es würden allen anderen
total den Wind aus den Segeln
nehmen. Die, die sich das
geben, denken selbst das glaube ich nicht.
Nachdenken ist nicht so verbreitet.
Das müsste man erklären.
Dann nimmst du komplett
den anderen Seiten auch den, den
Wind aus den Segeln.
Dann kommt keiner mehr an und erzählt,
dass irgendwie Bill Gates die
Leute zwangsimpfen will und mit Mikrochips
versorgen will und sonst was und das
Deckmantel der Corona-Maßnahmen
und bla und sonst was.
Man muss,
wenn man Entscheidungen trifft, das ist
jetzt nicht nur so von oben von der
Regierung herab,
man muss eigentlich immer, wenn man
Entscheidungen trifft, die Auswirkung auf
Leute haben, muss man
die erklären können. Wenn man die
erklären kann, dann ist die Chance
relativ gut, dass die Leute es
zumindest nachvollziehen können,
warum was passiert und man
überzeugt Leute viel einfacher
damit, wenn man ihnen erklärt, warum man
was macht, als wenn
man ihnen einfach sagt, wir machen das und so
ist es. Seit wann
interessieren sich Verschwörungstheoretiker
für Fucken? Es interessieren sich
relativ viele Leute für Fucken. Die
Hardcore-Verschwörungstheoretiker vielleicht
nicht. Allerdings sind
das ja Leute, die werden ja nicht als
Verschwörungstheoretiker geboren.
Ja, es gibt ein paar Leute,
die der Meinung sind, dass Obamas
Bodyguard ein Echsenmensch ist oder sowas.
Oder dass die Erde flach ist.
Oder dass Bill Gates uns Mikrochippen
will oder sowas. Aber
es werden auch Leute
mit der Zeit zu Verschwörungstheoretikern,
weil
sie überzeugt werden,
dass da was
dran sein muss.
Und wenn du auf der anderen Seite
die Sachen besser erklärst,
nimmst du denen
komplett den Wind aus den Segeln.
Hahaha, genau, Tribolon.
Der muss jetzt da durch noch kommen.
Naja, das vermisse
ich so ein bisschen. Bei vielen Sachen,
man muss das ordentlich erklären. Nur wenn man
Sachen ordentlich erklärt, kann man Leute
davon überzeugen. Kobol! Oh, hör mal auf, ey.
Alter, Kobol!
Aber wir machen noch einen
Kobol-Stream.
Heute ist ja nur aus der Reihe streamt.
Eigentlich,
ich war gerade einkaufen. Eigentlich habe ich da nur
ein paar Waffen-Attachments
frei.
Dann hab ich gedacht, nee, ich hab schon vier Tage nicht mehr gestreamt.
Ich muss jetzt ne Runde streamen.
Dann geh ich halt wieder
und mach was du willst.
Du musst aber, Moment,
Patrick,
ich sehe gerade, du musst noch
subscriben. So als
Obermod. Wie geht
das, ey?
Hast du schon was zu COD gesagt?
Ja, hab ich.
Nein, also Leute, keiner, ne?
Ich hab ja gerade gesagt, man muss
Sachen erklären und keiner
muss subscriben. Ich banne
niemanden, der nicht subscribt.
Oh, Clocks HD ist da.
Wobei,
vielleicht doch.
Man weiß ja nicht. Ja, nee.
Ich sehe es doch. Du hast doch diesen
First Subscription.
Ich glaube, das ist da mit dabei
irgendwie. Oder auch nicht.
Ach, was auch immer. Ist wurscht.
Hast du schon was zu COD gesagt?
Ich weiß, dass der Multiplayer scheiße ist, aber
Warzone und 2 vs 2 ganz gut ist.
Der Kommentator, das stimmt nicht.
Du hast 5 Monate
subscribed.
Fehlt da nicht noch was?
Geht das nicht noch weiter?
Ich glaube, das ist nur die halbe Copypasta.
Oh, glaub mir,
ich kenne viele Twitch-Copypastas.
Ach, Leute, wir müssen übrigens
noch was machen.
Äh, warte mal.
No happy meal for you. 10 Monate.
Dankeschön. Excellent Subscription.
Leute,
wir müssen jetzt mal was
checken.
Macht den Virgin-Check.
Das sind total
dämliche Copypasta, die ich letztens
gefunden habe.
Das ist richtig dumm, oder?
So.
Okay, ich wollte mir angucken,
was gerade auf GitHub trendet.
Ähm, was haben wir da?
Java-Zeugs.
Hör mal auf.
Muss das jetzt sein?
Wow, juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Facebook,
IOS, SDK, die machen vor nichts halt, oder?
Was ist das?
Super Mario 64
decompiled.
Ach, das kenne ich, das haben wir uns doch schon mal
angeguckt.
Ich glaube, die haben es mittlerweile sogar geschafft,
dass ein komplettes lauffähiges Game rauskommt.
Was ist das?
A new bootable
USB-Solution. Was ist das?
Äh,
ein USB-Stick?
Create bootable
USB-Drive for Isof... Hä?
...
Das ist ja so absolut nichts Neues, oder?
Da kann man USB-Sticks
machen mit Images drauf.
Ja gut, das macht dann ein fertiger USB-Stick
mit einem schönen Menü.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nett.
Das kann man bestimmt mal brauchen, das speichere ich mir.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich glaube, ich habe schon
seit einem Jahr nicht mehr
normalen Rechner
oder länger normalen Rechner
vom USB-Stick gebootet.
Moment, was?
Augmented Reality Copy & Paste.
Ah, irgendwelches...
VR Zeug.
Das ist so eine typische
JavaScript-Geschichte wieder.
Es gibt ja noch
nicht genug Bundler und
Mini-Fire für JavaScript.
Jetzt gibt es auch noch einen
Go.
Das ist so eine typische JavaScript-Geschichte.
Ich glaube,
es vergeht kein Tag, wo nicht 10 neue
gehypte
JavaScript-Libraries rauskommen.
Viel Spaß beim Einkaufen, ja?
Vielleicht findest du irgendwie
ein Kobold-Buch.
Wobei, ich glaube, im EDEKA haben die sowas nicht.
Frag doch mal im EDEKA nach einem Kobold-Buch.
Die denken dann, ja, ist das eine Zutat?
Irgendwie was zum Kochen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich da bin.
Ich kann es euch nicht sagen.
Ich habe nämlich überhaupt nichts vor hier im Stream,
geschweige denn, ich habe bloß gesehen,
Leute vier Tage immer gestreamt.
Da wird es mal echt wieder Zeit.
Was sollen denn die Leute hier machen auf Twitch,
wenn ich nicht streame?
Spiliarden ist bestimmt schon wieder
seit drei Tagen im Chat und
denkt sich, wann geht es da denn los?
Es gibt eine neue
Node-Library, um Chrome zu automatisieren.
Warum soll ich denn Chrome nochmal automatisieren?
Ach, das ist ein
Browser-Automatisierungstool,
was Chrome und Firefox
und WebKit
automatisieren. Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich
nicht schlecht.
Warstone on stream kann ich gar nicht, weil...
Okay, kann ich doch.
Machen wir aber nicht.
E-Mail-Leak.
Das ist die gleiche E-Mail, die kennt ihr alle.
Die geht auch für Donations und
Subscriptions und alles.
Da ist kein Leak.
Die steht sogar irgendwo hier
in den About,
im Channel irgendwo unter About.
Die ist nicht Secret.
Kein Leak.
Chat.
Aber wenn ihr wollt, ist es
meinetwegen ein Leak, wenn ihr euch besser fühlt.
Wenn ihr euch besser fühlt...
Fuck, Alter! Scheiße!
E-Mail-Adresse geleakt.
OMG!
Donations sind doch aus.
Ja, Donations sind aber nur aus,
weil der Donation-Link verbuggt war.
Übrigens habt ihr mitgekriegt,
dass in Overwatch
jetzt total viele
Pros abspringen?
Die keinen Bock mehr auf das Game haben und lieber Valorant
spielen?
Darklight drei Monate abonniert hat.
Dankeschön.
Massive Subscription.
Also Overwatch ist jetzt
ziemlich dead.
Ich frag mich, was die in ihrer Leak machen.
Die haben ein komplettes Team.
Eines der besten Teams überhaupt.
Haben die komplett gekickt
in der Overwatch-Leak.
Ich weiß nicht,
was da los ist.
Diese ganze Overwatch-Leak-Geschichte
war von Anfang an
kompletter Crap.
Kompletter gestellter
Fake-Hype.
Verpustet von Leuten,
die vom E-Sport keinen blassen Schimmer haben.
Und das zeigt sich jetzt.
Und das rächt sich jetzt.
Max, du hast dich im Battle.net-Launcher gespielt.
Oh fuck, Alter.
In der Suppe im Battle.net-Launcher.
Im Fernsehen.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Da ist er, los geht's mit Warzone-Coaching.
Easy.
Das ist echt was.
Das würde ich sogar streamen.
Muss ich mal gucken, ob ich irgendeinen guten Spieler finde,
der mal ordentlich coachen kann
in Warzone,
dass ich meinen zweieinhalb Monaten Rückstand
ein bisschen aufhole
über Game-Knowledge.
Keine
bekannten Leute.
Die besten Spieler
sind eh nicht welche,
die man groß kennt.
OWL war doch toll,
vor allem als Paris rauskam.
Die Overwatch-Maps,
das ist so ein Ding.
Ich hab, Leute,
mir fällt gerade was ein.
Overwatch-Maps sind scheiße.
Modern-Warfare-Maps sind scheiße.
Und seit ein paar Jahren
ist Blizzard
und Activision ganz dicke.
Da stimmt doch was nicht.
Da kann doch was
nicht stimmen.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind hier
wirklich auf der Spur.
Big Brain, ja.
Kann man ein Meme-Bot eigentlich ohne weiteres
selbst nutzen?
Es ist nur eine uralte Version
auf GitHub, aber die funktioniert.
Und was hat wohl Bill Gates damit
zu tun?
Ich glaube, Bill Gates hat
in den Sound-Files
der Spiele
versteckte Botschaften
hinterlassen,
die die Leute schon drauf einstimmen
sollen, beziehungsweise
den Widerstand brechen soll,
unbewusst gegen
Chip-Implantate.
Ich glaube,
wir sind hier wirklich was Großem auf der Spur.
So.
Was?
Kannst du eine Twitch-E-Grill-Tierliste
machen?
Nee.
Ich gucke kaum
weibliche Streamer.
Keine Ahnung, wer die besten
oder hottesten oder
was auch immer
besten Twitch-Grills sind.
Keine Ahnung.
Einzige Belegrate.
Ich glaube,
einzige
Streamerin,
der ich
follow und schon seit
Jahren,
ich weiß aber auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht,
warum ich da angefangen habe zu followen,
ist Miramisu.
Falls
sie jemand kennt.
Und ich gucke nicht oft,
aber die ist
nicht blöd. Also die Leute,
die tun immer so nach dem Motto,
ähm, so nach dem Motto,
alter Mädel, wie du dich hier gibst
im Stream und bla bla bla.
Die tun immer so oft moralisch,
aber rhetorisch own die
die teilweise schon ganz schön.
So die, so die ganzen
Flamerspasten im Chat.
Also die ist auf jeden Fall
nicht blöd.
Oh nein, Max, warum?
Aber da bin ich
der Fall, dir da eine Liste für zu machen.
Was? Hat sich schon
die IHK gemeldet?
Ähm.
Achso.
Ne.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendjemanden
interessiert bei der IHK.
Ja, mache ich nachher, mache ich nachher.
Keck W.
Müsstest du dann nicht doppelt das...
Oh, das ist eine interessante Frage, da wollte ich letztes Mal was dazu sagen.
Ich habe ja mein Netzwerk-Setup erklärt,
das letzte Mal, so mit Fritzbox für SIP und VoIP,
einen MikroTik-Router und davor
die Connect-Box von Vodafone.
Da hatte jemand gefragt, müsstest du dann nicht
die SIP nat machen, wenn auf der Fritzbox
vor dem MikroTik auch SIP laufen soll?
Ne, muss ich nicht.
Weil beide hängen ja
an der Connect-Box dran. Also es ist nicht so, dass mein
kompletter Traffic durch die Fritzbox gehen würde.
Was? E-Grill oder
E-Boy zum... Das kann ich nicht aufmachen.
Je nachdem, was das für eine Seite ist.
Ähm.
Das traue ich mich nicht aufzumachen.
Heute ein spezielles Vorhaben.
Ja, das spezielle Vorhaben ist,
dass ich nach vier Tagen mal wieder online komme
im Stream.
Nix.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute gar nicht online kommen.
Stand Vodafone.
Naja, also die letzten Tage hat es funktioniert.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass die zweite Nachricht,
die ich gekriegt habe, so wie vermutet,
wirklich von
irgendeinem Social-Media-Management-Typ
gekommen ist.
Weil die hat sich überhaupt nicht
nach einem Support-Mitarbeiter angehört,
die zweite Message. Habe ich euch ja vorgelesen.
Ich kann es nochmal vorlesen, für die, die nicht dabei waren.
Ähm.
Haben die das jetzt gefixt?
Wahrscheinlich bin ich in irgendeine
Liste gerutscht.
Größer gleich 10k Follower
auf Twitter, auf YouTube, sonst was.
Bitte fixen.
Ja, weil die erste Nachricht, die ich gekriegt habe,
wir haben hier extra schon eine Liste
für Vodafone
Ausreden.
Vodafone Ausreden.
Erstmal die WLAN-SSID
doppelt. Modem-Werte
schlechte Einstrahlung, Modem-Neustarten.
Ähm. Es gibt Probleme,
mit der Connect-Box deutschlandweit.
Modem-Neustarten, Modem-Neustarten.
Großraumstörung im Raum Hanau Frankfurt.
Und danach habe ich die Nachricht
gekriegt.
Ähm. Einmal vom Support.
Hallo, wir sind diesbezüglich informiert
und arbeiten gerade daran, die Störung zu
beheben. Und eine Viertelstunde
später, das war nach dem dritten
oder vierten Tag in Folge,
wo wir Probleme haben, wo ich jeden Abend
rumgespammt habe auf Twitter.
Habe ich dann eine Nachricht gekriegt, die sich so
überhaupt gar nicht nach Support
liest. Und zwar,
vielen Dank für deine Nachricht. Tut mir leid zu lesen,
dass dein Stream beeinträchtigt ist.
Leider gibt es da im Moment eine Großstörung
in deinem
Anschlussbereich.
Die Technik arbeitet mit Hochdruck an der
Behebung. Das sollte bald erledigt sein.
Bitte hab noch etwas Geduld. Wenn alles wieder
läuft, kannst du uns gerne wieder schreiben. Dann
können wir uns um eine entsprechende Gutschrift kümmern.
Ich wünsche dir einen schönen Tag. Liebe Grüße.
Das klingt so null nach den
Support-Nachrichten von vorher.
Ich hab so irgendwie das Gefühl, dass es
irgendein Social-Media-Management-Typ
ist. Und der sich jetzt gedacht hat,
oh fuck, der spammt jetzt jeden Abend,
wie scheiße wir sind.
Vielleicht sollten wir das mal fixen.
Hast du schon
das Drama wegen dem neuen Twitch-Konzil mitbekommen?
Ne, ich hab das Drama mitgenommen
um die Corona-Warn-
App.
Da
drehen die Leute wieder ab.
Ah,
wo ist das denn? Die sind wieder
am diskutieren in der Corona-Warn-App.
Das ist also
auf dem GitHub-Repo von der deutschen
Corona-Warn-App sind sie
gerade wieder am diskutieren, ob es
nicht
Leute beleidigt,
wenn man
eher sie und
Anrede nicht gendergerecht verwendet.
Das ist natürlich das allergrößte
Problem, was man bei einer Corona-Warn-App
hat.
Ob die Gender-Bezeichnungen
richtig sind. Logischerweise.
Was könnte bei so einer Corona-App denn sonst wichtig sein?
Nicht Warp.
Wie heißt denn
das Repo nochmal, Leute?
Corona-Warn-App heißt das Ding.
Auf GitHub, genau.
Wo ist der GitHub-Link?
Ja.
Ich mach mal Achtung, Leute.
Augenwarnung.
So, und
die haben nur
wenn ihr hier guckt, was hier
Closed ist,
was
da wieder diskutiert
wird.
Geschlechtssensitive
Sprache in deutschen Dokumenten.
Oh mein Gott, das ist unglaublich
für eine Corona-App. Das geht nicht.
Alter,
die drehen echt alle ab.
Naja, was auch immer. Es ist egal.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn wir echt
keine Probleme haben bei einer Corona-Warn-App,
als dass die
genderkorrekte Bezeichnung drin ist, dann
weiß ich auch nicht.
Was hat jemand eben gefragt, ob ich
irgendwelches Twitch-Drama mitbekommen hab?
Hast du schon das Drama um den neuen
Twitch-Concile mitbekommen?
Moment, was ist das?
Hä?
Was soll das sein?
Moment.
Warte.
Ja.
Was?
Was hat das jetzt mit Twitch?
Was hat das jetzt mit Twitch-Skandal zu tun?
Hä?
Wo ist da jetzt...
Verstehe ich nicht.
Hä?
Es gibt Sachen, die verstehe ich nicht.
Also...
Hä?
Die ist bei dem neuen Twitch-Safety-Advisor-Konzil.
Was ist ein Twitch-Safety-Advisory-Konzil?
Okay.
Oh, ich sehe schon, in welche Richtung das führt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das jetzt geben will.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dazu im Stream wieder was sagen soll.
Okay.
Ich ahne schon, in welche Richtung das geht, aber...
Ähm, mal gucken.
Wir sind ja aktuell gerade überall sehr drauf bedacht,
dass sich auch, ja, keiner in irgendeiner Art und Weise mehr gekränkt fühlt.
Was im Endeffekt darauf rausläuft,
dass das noch mehr Leute eigentlich als vorher...
Aber halt vielleicht andere...
Ähm, ja.
Okay, also sogar auf Deutsch.
Okay.
Die Sicherheit und Gesundheit unserer Community hat für Twitch oberste Priorität.
Das ist auch schön.
Wir freuen uns deshalb heute, die Gründung des Twitch-Sicherheitsbeirats anzukündigen,
der in Zukunft das Wachstum unserer Community unterstützen würde.
Also, wenn ich an das Thema Sicherheitsbeirat denke,
ähm, das Erste, was mir in den Sinn kommt, ist sowas wie Account-Sicherheit
oder dass man schaut, dass die Leute nicht so sehr scammen und debaten können
mit Short-Urls und solche Geschichten.
Das würde ich jetzt...
Das...
Das klingt für mich jetzt erstmal nach Sicherheitsbeirat.
So.
Der Sicherheitsbeirat wird Informieren und Entscheidungen von Twitch anleiten,
indem er seine Erfahrung und Expertise sowie sein Glauben an die Mission von Twitch einbringt.
Den Satz habe ich nicht verstanden.
Was?
Der Sicherheitsbeirat wird Informieren und Entscheidungen von Twitch anleiten.
Was ist eigentlich hier mit den Buchstaben los, wenn man die markiert?
Indem er seine Erfahrung und Expertise...
Indem er seine Erfahrung und Expertise sowie seinen Glauben an die Mission von Twitch...
Den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Wirklich low-brain.
Ich verstehe den Satz nicht.
Okay, machen wir mal weiter.
Communities dabei zu unterstützen, zusammen etwas zu erschaffen.
Das ist bestimmt aus dem Englischen übersetzt.
Der Satz leuchtet mir nicht so ganz ein, aber okay.
Vielleicht bin ich einfach zu low-IQ dafür.
Der Rat wird unter anderem bei folgenden Themen beraten.
Entwurf neue Richtlinien, Aktualisierung...
Das ist doch nicht verkehrt.
Also ich meine, inwieweit die jetzt was zu sagen haben, ist mal fraglich.
Letztendlich wird Twitch nach wie vor sagen, wir machen die Sachen so, wie wir sie machen wollen.
Aber Leute, ich kann nicht beurteilen, wer da am Start ist und welche Expertise die Leute haben.
Nur mal auch für die Idee gesprochen, ist das doch eigentlich gar nicht schlecht,
so eine Art Gremium aus erfahrenen Streamern und Leuten zu haben,
die sich nicht so sehr auf die Idee stellen,
die sich halt auskennen, was quasi die Twitch-Community so mag und haben will
und das sich dann kurz schließt mit Twitch, wenn es um Regeländerungen geht.
Das klingt doch jetzt erstmal gar nicht so blöd.
So.
Ich meine, da könnte man zum Beispiel dann auch mal wirklich den einen oder anderen Kontroversen reinsetzen,
der sich schon öfter mal in die Brennnesseln gesetzt hat,
so einen wie xQc zum Beispiel.
Ähm.
Der nur schon öfter mal drunter, weiß ich, es war ja, es war ja oftmals auch zu Recht,
aber auch schon ein bisschen drunter zu leiden hatte, dass manche Sachen sehr, sehr, sehr schwammig sind.
Ich erinnere nur mal an diese ganze Geschichte mit, ähm,
wenn man tryhard postet, wäre das racist und sowas.
Ich finde, so Sachen könnte man schon klarer in, in Richtlinien regeln.
Wobei das auch so ein Zusammenspiel aus Overwatch League und Twitch am Ende gewesen ist.
Ich meine, der, der rein, das reine Benutzen,
eines offiziellen Emotes, ohne, ohne Text, ohne Kontext, was auch immer, rein, das Benutzen eines Emotes kann ja wohl kaum großartig racist sein.
Das ist ja nicht umsonst ein offizielles Twitch-Emote.
Wenn jetzt einer hergeht und eine, keine Ahnung, ein Hakenkreuz in, in, in, in Better Twitch TV macht,
das ist mal wieder was ganz, was anderes.
Aber wir reden ja über offizielle Twitch-Emotes.
So.
Entwicklung von Produkten und Funktionen zur Erhöhung von Sicherheit und Moderation.
Klingt doch auch sinnvoll.
Förderung gesunder Streaming und Work-Life-Balance-Gewohnheiten.
Okay.
Schutz der Interessen von Randgruppen.
Man muss, das ist halt, wo man sich immer auf dünnem Eis bewegt.
Man muss bei dieser ganzen Sache immer gucken, also ich bin, ich bin rein für die Sache, bin ich voll dafür.
Man muss allerdings immer gucken, dass es nicht ins komplette Gegenteil umschlägt.
Zum Beispiel.
Ähm.
So nach dem Motto, wir sind jetzt alle Feministen, deswegen sind jetzt auf einmal alle, alle Männer Trash.
Wisst ihr, dann, dann hat man im Prinzip, außer, dass man das einmal geflippt hat, so wer jetzt, wer, wer jetzt Trash ist und wer jetzt Hate abbekommt,
hat man einfach einmal umgedreht.
Das ist ja auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der, der, der, der, der Sachen, ja.
Also Schutz von Interessen von Randgruppen, klar, immer.
Ähm, allerdings muss man halt gucken, dass nicht andere,
das ist halt, das ist schwierig, ja, wenn man, das ist auch so ein Thema, wo man es nie allen recht machen kann.
Okay, also diese Gruppe besteht aus Online-Sicherheitsexperten und Twitch-Creatoren.
Ich denke bei Sicherheitsexperten und gerade bei Online-Sicherheitsexperten wirklich an, an Security.
Und, und ich, ich habe halt das Gefühl jetzt, so wie ich das lese und das war sowas, ja, Gefühl ist ja immer das Allerwichtigste, ne.
Wissen wir ja.
Ne, also ich habe das Gefühl, denen, denen geht es bei Sicherheit eher so um, um Safe.
In Form von, ähm, es wird nicht gehatet, es wird nicht geflamed, es ist, wir haben uns alle lieb, wohlfühlen, wohlfühlen und sowas.
Die meinen mit Sicherheit, glaube ich, gar nicht IT-Security.
Ähm, Safe Spaces, genau, wie sie das immer auf Englisch nennen.
Also diese Gruppe besteht aus Online-Sicherheitsexperten, oh, richtig, richtig nice Musik.
Äh, und Twitch-Creatoren, die ein tiefer gehendes Verständnis von Twitch sowie dessen Inhalt und seiner Kombi, das ist doch gut.
Beim Zusammenstellen dieses, ich bin, ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wer da alles drin ist, äh.
Äh, beim Zusammenstellen dieses Rates haben wir darauf geachtet, sowohl Experten mit einer externen Perspektive als auch Twitch-Streamer mit einem tiefen Verständnis.
Wozu braucht man da externe Experten? Das geht doch um Twitch-Content, oder?
Man fragt die Leute, die Twitch-Content machen.
Mit einem tiefen Verständnis für die einzigartigen Herausforderungen und Ansichten eines Creators, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Jedes Mitglied dieses Rates, ähm.
Moment.
Äh, jedes, jedes Mitglied dieses Rates wurde sorgfältig ausgewählt, wobei die Vertrautheit mit der Twitch-Community und der relevante persönliche und berufliche Erfahrungsschatz berücksichtigt wurde.
Wir freuen uns sehr, mit dieser talentierten Gruppe zusammenzuarbeiten und besten Ort für Aufbau und Erhalt einer Community zu machen.
Die Gründung des Sicherheitsbeirats ist nur eine der Maßnahmen, die wir im Namen von Vertrauen und Sicherheit vornehmen.
Wir investieren weiterhin in, okay, bla, okay, wer ist da dabei?
Kenn, kenn ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Äh, den kenn ich.
Den kenn ich, da hab ich sogar schon ein paar, paar, ähm, Streams geguckt, aber zu wenig, dass ich da irgendwas drüber aussagen könnte.
Kenn ich nicht.
Kenn ich auch nicht.
Ah, das ist, wo wir das Video eben gesehen haben.
Keine Ahnung.
Kenn ich auch nicht.
Den kenn ich!
Das ist ein Path of Exile-Streamer.
Den guck ich gerne.
Gerne.
Okay.
Okay, halt mal fest, ich kenne, ich kenne zwei Leute, das heißt jetzt nix, mir nur aufgefallen, so, ich kenn, ich kenn, ich kenn zwei Leute, ähm, aus der, aus der Liste, ähm, gut, zu sagen, haben sie natürlich nix, letztendlich, aber, mal ganz ehrlich, wie war's denn bisher auf Twitch?
Oder wie ist es denn, wie ist es denn auf allen, ich, ich sag mal auf nahezu, auf allen mir bekannten, äh.
Äh, äh, Plattformen, wie Twitch, oder YouTube, oder, was hat man da sonst noch, äh, Facebook Gaming, keine Ahnung, Mixer, was es nicht alles gibt, ja, es ist doch auf allen so, dass du, letztendlich als, als Creator auf Gedeih und Verderben der Plattform ausgeliefert bist.
So, und, dass Twitch jetzt nicht sagt, wir nehmen da irgendeinen Beirat.
An sieben schwierigen Leuten, die dann auch noch quasi ein, ein, ein festes Veto-Recht haben, kann ich verstehen, ist doch, äh, das wäre doch aus, aus, aus Sicht von Twitch, überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht anzustreben.
So, und natürlich nimmt man sich jetzt auch Leute, die, äh, mit denen man wohl gut auskommt, aber auf der anderen Seite, wo, wo genau ist denn jetzt der Shitstorm bei der ganzen Geschichte, den verstehe ich doch nicht so genau.
Hast du schon mitbekommen, dass Facebook Giphy gekauft hat? Nee.
Also, ich verstehe, also, wo, wo, wo genau ist, warum, wo ist da jetzt, wo ist da jetzt der Beef?
Ich glaube, die Leute sind wegen dieser Transgender-Personen-Märkte, warum?
Pff, die haben sie doch nicht mal alle.
Man darf auf alle Leute sauer sein.
Ja, das ist, ist okay, berechtigt, wenn sie irgendwas gesagt haben, was einen nicht anpisst, äh, was einen anpisst, kann man sauer sein.
Also.
Weil, ich meine, nur, weil er, oder sie, weiß nicht, wie, äh, wie man sie eher ihn jetzt richtig nennt, weil das ist ja schmierig, deswegen sage ich jetzt mal sie, ähm, und nur, weil sie, keine Ahnung, bunte Haare hat, warum sollte man auf jemanden sauer sein?
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Die können echt alle machen, was sie wollen.
Und wenn einer heute sagt, er wäre gerne ein Fahrrad, kann er das meinetwegen.
Man sollte nur nicht davon ausgehen, dass es auf jeden Fall die restliche Welt dann sofort versteht.
Aber ansonsten, ey, Vira, jeder, jeder Vira will.
Also, warum man sich jetzt darüber aufregt, okay, warte mal, Reddit, Twitch, worüber regen sie sich denn jetzt auf?
Gar nicht, oder?
Oh, oh!
Das ist schlecht.
Die, die dürfen IRC nicht entfernen.
Das ist viel schlimmer.
Die dürfen IRC nicht entfernen.
Dann geht, dann geht mein, dann geht mein Chatlogger nicht mehr, wenn die IRC entfernen.
Mein Chatlogger basiert auf, auf, auf, auf der IRC, auf, dass, dass der Twitch-Chat über IRC erreichbar ist.
Ach so.
Okay, an, okay, sie, sie entfernen nicht IRC, sie, sie entfernen ein paar IRC-Features, das müsste immer noch funktionieren.
Wieso benutzt du nicht BRC, wenn die IRC entfernen?
Excellent.
Warum man jetzt daran rumdoktern muss?
Verstehe ich allerdings trotzdem nicht.
Also, ich sehe hier ehrlich gesagt kein Geflame über den Sicherheitsrad.
Die können alle...
Okay, anscheinend das hier.
Nee, nee, ich, ich will mich damit gar nicht weiter beschäftigen.
Es ist wie auf YouTube, eigentlich ist mir scheißegal, was die Plattform macht.
Ich stelle hier meinen Content zur Verfügung, im Endeffekt, ja, weil ich hier die Leute am besten erreichen kann und wir haben ja auch hier den besten, der besten...
Moment.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten ist mir das vollkommen egal, was die Plattform macht.
Wenn die nicht gerade komplett geisteskranke Dinger beschließen, sodass ich keinen Bock mehr drauf habe, hier zu streamen, ist mir das ziemlich egal.
Du musst erst mal die Basics machen, ja.
Wie spricht man es richtig aus?
Basics, ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
Wie spricht man Basics richtig aus?
Die Basics.
Du musst, du musst, du musst mal die Basics machen.
Basics, ne?
Musst die Basics.
Ist das Schwäbisch?
Das ist bestimmt Schwäbisch.
Schwäbisch ist, ist nen...
Hessisch, das ist doch gar nicht hessisch.
Das ist nicht hessisch.
Also ich weiß, wie sich hessisch anhört, aber, aber die Basics sagt dir keiner.
Das sagt keiner hier, die Basics.
Stuttgarter Dialekt, ja, das ist Schwäbisch, ja.
Wie findest du San Diego Spongeboss?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenn mich im deutschen Hip-Hop-Segment nicht.
Ich kenn mich im deutschen Hip-Hop-Segment nicht aus, ähm, aber ich kann was zum schwedischen Dialekt sagen, auf die Gefahr hin, dass jetzt ein paar Leute schlägig sind, aber, ich muss euch auch erklären warum, ich mag schwäbischen Dialekt nicht.
Das liegt daran, weil mein erster Arbeitgeber, ähm, der Provider, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht hab, meine Ausbildung gemacht hab, die kam aus Ulm.
Und die haben alle schwäbisch geredet und das war ein echt komischer Laden.
Ja, also ich hab nichts gegen Schwaben, aber immer wenn ich einen schwäbisch reden höre, ähm, dann muss ich daran denken.
Ja, wenn dich fragt, sag einfach beste.
Ich sag selten beste zu was, was ich gar nicht kenne.
Weil im Zweifelsfall ist es nicht beste, sondern sagt, oh nee, Nekorock, das kenn ich noch.
Oh nein, das kenn ich noch.
Das ist das Zwischending, was immer, das ist diese Zwischenschau, die immer im ersten Programm läuft.
In Hessen laufen im zweiten, sind Mainzelmännchen, im ersten ist Onkel Otto und im Schwäbischen ist es dieser Affe und der Esel im Fernsehprogramm.
Das kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Ich war ja manchmal über Nacht dort in Ulm und da habe ich auch ein bisschen Fernsehen geguckt und da kamen diese komischen Zwischeneinspieler mit dem Esel und dem Affe immer.
Das hier, das hier, da denke ich mit Horror dran.
Hör mal auf, nein, nein, nein, nein, das erinnert mich an Zeiten, wo ich mich nicht gerne dran erinnere.
Ansonsten muss ich sagen, wo wir gerade bei Dialekten sind, es gab ja mal irgendeine Abstimmung, dass, ich glaube, Sächsisch oder so wäre der unsexiestes Dialekt
oder der, der, irgendwie der, der...
Der, keine Ahnung, dümmste Dialekt oder so, keine Ahnung.
Ich muss ja sagen, dass ich irgendwo Sächsisch noch ganz gut finde.
Vielleicht, weil ich den Fabian und den Carsten kenne, aber die reden ja beide nicht so richtig krass Sächsisch.
Da habe ich keine Schmerzen mit.
Also, dass der einzige Dialekt, der mir wirklich auf den Keks geht, ist Schwemisch.
Und eben, weil ich da persönliche Erfahrungen mit habe.
Ansonsten ist mir das eigentlich vollkommen wurscht, ob es jetzt einer Bayerisch labert, Sächsisch, irgendwie Norddeutsches Zeug oder sonst wie.
Was ich geil finde, also eine Sache, die mir aufgefallen ist, so an Sächsisch.
Und ich war ja auch schon drei, viermal oder so, viermal oder so, glaube ich, in Dresden.
Dass im Osten sagen total viele Leute immer nü.
So wie wir hier, so wie wir sagen ach oder hä oder was, sagen die nü.
Aber so langgezogen, so nü.
Ich kann das nicht nachmachen.
Und nü, nü, nü.
Ich kann das nicht nachmachen, aber ihr wisst wahrscheinlich, was ich meine.
Krelaks, sechs Monate, danke schön.
Excellent.
Subscription.
In Hessen sagt man hä.
Hä geht für alles.
Nü gibt es nur in Dresden, sonst nirgends.
Okay.
Ja.
So genau kenne ich mich da nicht aus.
So gibt es ja noch ein paar sinnvolle Fragen.
Max, kannst du mir sagen, was WPAD ist?
WPAD, das hört sich an, wie wenn man Leerzeichen auffüllt.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das damit gemeint ist.
Man paddelt Leerzeichen, Whitespaces oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Was hältst du denn von Deno bisher?
Wie gesagt, ich habe mir ein paar Webcasts dazu angeguckt.
Ich sehe die Vorteile gegenüber Node.js.
Allerdings, was ich nicht verstehe, ist, warum man das verwenden sollte.
Das Wichtigste an dem ganzen Ökosystem von Node.js ist doch, dass es so viele Pakete gibt.
Und die gibt es für Deno nicht.
Voice Chat abgeschafft, weil es diskriminierend ist.
Da der Blödsinn aus.
Was denn?
Mittlerweile heutzutage ist alles diskriminierend.
Äh.
Magst du XQC?
Ähm.
Ich habe früher viel XQC geguckt.
Allerdings, ich kann es mir nicht mehr angucken.
Aktuell.
Das liegt aber nicht an ihm, sondern weil...
Ich meine, der Chat war schon immer Cancer, aber das hat dazu gehört.
Aber mittlerweile sind es so viele Leute im Chat, dass du auch nicht mehr die witzigen Situationen von so einem PPGuard Chat hast, wie früher.
Früher hast du halt irgendetwas total Hirnverbranntes gepostet.
Und da haben die Leute quasi noch darauf Reacted im Chat.
Oder umgedreht.
Du hast auf etwas Dummes reagiert, was Leute im Chat geschrieben haben.
Aber das geht mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Mittlerweile spammen die Leute einfach nur 150 Zeichen Emotes am Stück.
Oder machen Donations.
Wer es kennt, weiß, was ich meine.
Total hängen geblieben.
Deswegen kann ich mir das nicht mehr angucken.
Any Juicers.
Ja.
Ansonsten muss man sagen,
XQC hat schon Twitch ganz schön seinen Stempel aufgedrückt.
Also viele Sprüche und viele Ausdrücke
ist quasi mittlerweile fast Gang und Gebe auf Twitch.
Zum Beispiel, go a-garn.
A-garne.
Tryhard 7, ja, ist auch sowas, genau.
Wie geht's dem Fabian?
Dem geht's gut.
Gut, er spielt Mobile Games.
Du hast ja erwähnt, dass du bei einer Bank arbeitest.
Kennst du Star Money?
Ja, kenne ich.
Habe aber nicht.
Das ist doch eher was, wo man daheim sein Rechnungswesen-Zeug machen kann.
Wann kommt das Staubsauger-Minecraft-Let's-Play?
Das funktioniert nicht so richtig.
Es gibt keine grafische Ausgabe auf dem Ding.
Auch nicht über SSH, das läuft nicht.
Wenn der Friseur Mobile Games spielt, kann es ihm nicht gut gehen.
Doch, tatsächlich.
Der findet das super.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da los ist.
Hast du schon die neue Tech-Demo von der neuen Unreal Engine angesehen?
Nö.
Es gibt eine neue Unreal Engine?
Echt?
Unreal Engine 5 Demo?
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
Die neue Tech-Demo ist geisteskrank.
Ach, Patrick, du bist ja doch noch da.
Huge.
Poggers.
Leute, ich habe ein Problem.
Ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Was machen wir denn da?
Ich mache euch den Pepega-Song an.
Ähm.
Ich gehe jetzt...
Ihr dürft euch jetzt das Aquarium und den Zug angucken.
Und ich mache 5 Minuten Pause und gehe aufs Klo.
Aber das allerwichtigste, Chat.
Dass ihr nicht irgendwie auf die Idee kommt, hier, jetzt, während ich weg bin,
Exklusiv-Chat 2.0 zu machen.
Außer AnyGifters im Chat.
Die dürfen natürlich.
Ähm.
Gehe ich jetzt auf mein Handy und mache meinen Chat auf.
So.
Ich sehe euch.
So, ich bin in 5 Minuten wieder da.
Ich mache vielleicht nochmal kurz ein Overlay.
Text.
Kurz.
Auf Klo.
Perfekt.
So, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Gleich wieder am Start.
Ohne wie man jetzt sagen würde, Bruder muss groß.
So.
Chat.
Ich habe alles gesehen.
Jetzt werde ich erstmal 20 Leute bannen.
Enemy is in a dirty abode.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Also, Unreal 5 Tech Reveal.
Unreal Engine 5 Revealed.
Puh.
Dann bekommst du viele Nudes von Fans geschenkt.
Ja, ich kann mich vor Dickpics kaum noch retten.
Hahaha.
Afgtext.
Mal gucken, ob unsere Bandbreite eingestellt, richtig eingestellt ist.
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay.
Äh, die Musik sollte ich vielleicht mal ausmachen.
Nix-Leak.
Der Chat.
So einfach kann ich nicht debated werden.
Es ist weder IP-Leak noch Stream-Key-Leak.
Okay.
Unreal Engine 5 Revealed.
Schauen wir uns das doch mal an.
Bisschen lauter, hä?
Hallo, I'm Brian Karras, Technical Director of Graphics here at Epic Games.
Hi, I'm Jérôme Pléthore, Art Director of the Special Project.
Oh, oui, oui.
A few years ago, we got together as a team and brainstormed,
where we thought we could push forward state-of-the-art and real-time graphics.
There were two key areas that stood out.
The first, dynamic global illumination.
Beautiful bounce lighting, instantaneously.
Oh, Zeug, ja.
I'd like to be constrained to do a game where the world has to be static.
And I'm able to iterate a lot faster.
And we call this new system Lumen.
We are about to show you what it is capable of.
But first, there was another area that we thought we could push forward.
Sitzen die nicht viel zu nah beieinander?
Und ganz ohne Maske?
And that's a big deal for artists.
I just want to be able to import my ZBrush model,
my photographic scan, my CAD data,
without wasting any time optimizing, creating LODs,
or even lowering the quality to make it hit frame rate.
In the end, that's what it's all about.
Art that just works.
And we call this new technology Nanite.
Here is the future of Unreal Engine running live on a PlayStation 5.
Okay, das ist interessant.
Dass es auf einer PS5 läuft.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sich die Specs angeguckt hat,
da geht's mal wenigstens ein bisschen vorwärts wieder.
Mit Hardware und Konsolen.
Ist nicht mehr so enttäuschend wie bei der Xbox One und bei der PS4 zu Release.
Bester Glück erledigt.
Okay, ich mach auch mal unten mal die Leiste weg.
Ist das Fortnite 2?
Oh, die Beleuchtung sieht schon geil aus.
Das sieht schon wirklich gut aus.
Also das sieht wirklich gut aus. Guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt mal.
Also mal an.
Denkt euch mal die Overlays weg.
Und sowas.
Also das hier könnte ohne Probleme...
Okay, wenn man sich das Gras anguckt und es pixelt und so.
Ja, okay.
Wenn jemand zu einem sagen würde,
sag mir mal, ob das Foto echt ist oder 3D gerendert.
Dann würdest du sagen, okay, vielleicht 3D gerendert.
Aber wenn dir das Foto einer kontextlos zeigen würde,
also ich glaube nicht, dass es direkt einem ins Auge springen würde.
Na, das Gras erkennt man schon.
Aber mal angenommen, es würde euch eine Landschaftsaufnahme zeigen
und da würde das dazwischen liegen.
Also da sieht das schon ganz gut aus.
Was? Der Stream pixelt? Echt jetzt?
Allzu viel sollte da eigentlich gar nicht mal pixeln.
Okay, wahrscheinlich halt das übliche.
Es könnte, na gut, die Kompression ist natürlich ein bisschen schlechter.
Die sieht hier auf YouTube schon besser aus, das stimmt.
Was ich cool fände, ein FPS-Counter.
Ach Chat, ich glaube euch kein Wort.
Boah, Wood Face.
Monkeys.
Wisst ihr, woran mich das erinnert?
Hat irgendjemand dieses Unlimited Detail Video gesehen vor ein paar Jahren?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Unlimited Detail.
Wo bis heute nichts rausgekommen ist.
16 times the details, genau.
Oh Mann.
Chat.
Meine Güte.
Wie ich hier wieder, wie ich hier wieder gebetet werde.
Mikro aus, sonst was.
Natürlich ist da nix aus.
Zumal, ich hör's ja selbst.
Ich spiel mich ja, ich spiel mich ja selbst wieder ein.
Der Chat ist heut hart am dauernd gebeten.
This amount of geometric detail requires shadows to be pixel accurate as well.
And then I can do that too.
Speaking of lighting, all of the lighting in this demo is completely dynamic.
With the power of Lumen, that even includes multi-bounce global illumination.
No lightmaps, no baking here.
Without GI, all of that beautiful lighting is gone.
With Lumen enabled, we can move the light and the bounce changes instantly.
Okay, let's keep going.
Also die Belichtung sieht wirklich extrem gut aus.
Man ist das wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig zu schätzen, aber es sieht wirklich sehr nice aus.
We can make some early additions to our audio system as well.
Convolution reverb allows us to measure reverberation characteristics of real spaces.
Ist wirklich schon mal jemand so gesprungen?
Das frage ich mich bei...
Ich weiß, das hat mit der Grafik überhaupt nichts zu tun, ja.
Das ist genauso wie in Uncharted.
Fünf Meter gesprungen, hingehangen und dann an einem Arm da gehangen.
Und sich gedacht.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Ich hänge hier an einem Arm rum.
Ich gucke jetzt erstmal kurz entspannt nach unten.
Und dann mache ich BÄM, hochziehen.
Gar kein Problem.
Jetzt wird hier durchgestelzt, ja.
Jetzt muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Wie sieht denn das Licht auf der Haut aus beim Durchlaufen?
Das sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Ich meine, das sieht wirklich sehr nah an dem aus, wie ich mir das vorstellen würde, wie es halt aussieht.
This swarm of bats was created with our Niagara effects system.
Particles in Niagara can now talk to one another and understand their environment like never before.
We also added a ton of new functionality to run fluid simulations like you see in the water below.
Ja, am Wasser habe ich jetzt nicht so viel erkannt.
Das Wasser sah eher so aus, als haben sie drauf, passt nicht so 100% zur Animation.
Aber Wasser ist doch heute schon ziemlich, ziemlich real.
The demo runs on our chaos physics system.
Here we are using it to accurately simulate the rigid bodies of the falling stars.
Here we are using it to accurately simulate the rigid bodies of the falling rocks.
And the cloth of her scarf.
Das ist doch nicht anstrengend.
Vor allem, woran klettert sie denn? Bitteschön.
Now that the environment is so complex, we've needed to greatly improve our animation systems to adapt.
We've added predictive foot placement and motion warping, which dynamically modifies eye-
Das ist cool, dass sowas dabei ist.
Da kann quasi jetzt auch, ähm, jeder dahergelaufene Typ einen SSC machen.
... und Körperposition, um es natürlicher zu sehen.
Um den Charakter mit dem Umfeld mehr realistisch zu interagieren, haben wir die Möglichkeit,
unendliche kontextuelle Animationen zu triggeren, wie ihre Hand auf der Tür.
Das ist ja ein bisschen versichert.
Ähm, PClustig sagt, aber was davon dann wirklich in Games ankommt,
das ist doch bei Unreal bisher immer ziemlich, ziemlich gut alles auch in Games angekommen.
Wenn man sich die Unreal-Demos anguckt, 3, 4, 5,
ich überleg grad, was waren die Unreal-Demo 4?
An die 3er kann ich mich erinnern.
Das war dieser Samariter, Samaritan, oder wie man das ausspricht.
Der Typ, der die Leute rumboxt.
Was war denn der Unreal-4-Trailer nochmal?
War doch dieses Zimmer?
Wir gucken uns danach nochmal den Unreal-4-Trailer an.
Ich kann mich an den Unreal-4-Trailer nicht mehr erinnern.
Ich kann mich doch an den Unreal-3-Trailer erinnern.
Dynamic GI is amazing, not just for speeding up iteration,
but also for its impact and gameplay.
Any light source can move while still having beautiful bounce lagging.
Dynamic Illumination means specular as well, which you can see on all the metal surfaces.
You can even see the Niagara-powered bugs reacting to the light.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie es glänzt? Das ist cool.
Lumen not only reacts to moving light sources, but also changes in geometry.
Remember we mentioned high-poly assets?
This statue was imported directly from ZBrush and has more than 33 million triangles.
No baking of normal maps, no authored LODs.
And we can do more than a single statue.
There are nearly 500 of that exact statue at the same detail level placed in this room
for a total of over 16 billion triangles from statues alone.
Und was haben die für eine Hardware drinne?
Over this entire demo...
Ach nee, ist ja PS5. Haben sie ja gesagt.
Normale PS5.
So with Mana you have limitless geometry.
And with Lumen you have fully dynamic lighting and global illumination.
All running on PlayStation 5.
Level up.
There's not much time left.
This doesn't need to be constrained to small rooms.
It can stretch all the way to the horizon.
Ich denke mal, das sind eher 30 FPS. Ich glaube nicht, dass das mit 60 läuft hier.
Was haben wir denn?
Es ist auch nicht...
Sagen wir mal so.
Es ist nicht wirklich zu erkennen, weil das Video halt selbst nur mit 30 ist.
Was für eine Grafikkarte ist vergleichbar mit einer PS5?
Oh, ich habe es nicht mehr richtig im Kopf.
Ich glaube eine 2070 oder so, ne?
So um den Dreh um eine 2070, glaube, war das.
Kann auch sein, dass ich jetzt komplett falsch liege.
Ich kriege es...
Ich kriege es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr richtig zusammen.
The portal is open.
Portal 3 confirmed.
Oh, du kannst hier rausgehen.
Oh, soll ich da rein?
Oh, das ist die nächste Chance.
Was soll ich da jetzt machen?
Ich muss so weit raus...
Ja, ich auch.
Wir haben hier die letzte Chance.
Ach, du kannst hier nicht nach oben gehen.
Aber du kannst arbeiten.
Es wird so langsam.
Okay.
Warte mal.
Wir haben das noch nicht abgeschafft.
Sh0ment.
Das ist cool.
Was?
Ist das eine große Scheibe, wie man das durchtrennt?
Stehen die aber garantiert vor dertur.
Weiß.
Oh.
gekriegt hat. Dieses
Glitzer-Ding.
Ultra nice.
Wie gesagt, ich bin, ich kenne mich
mit 3D-Programmierzeug und
Grafik null aus. Ich hab da
nur absolut Basic. Das Einzige,
was ich bisher mal OpenGL wirklich
from scratch RAW-mäßig programmiert
hab, ist die Teekanne.
Die Teekanne mit OpenGL.
Die Basic-Teekanne.
Das sind ungefähr so
50 Zeilen oder so.
Die OpenGL-Teekanne ist das
Einzige, was ich je programmiert hab. So richtig
Low-Level-3D.
Und was ist mit Lull-3D?
Ja, das
genau. Das ist die Unreal-4-Demo.
Richtig, richtig, richtig.
Ich erinnere mich. Das ist, ja,
genau dieses Flammending.
Ja.
Moment. Das brauchen wir
in höherer Auflösung.
What?
Ah.
Und denkt dran,
es ist sieben Jahre her, was wir jetzt sehen.
Sieben Jahre.
Stimmt, jetzt kann ich mich wieder an die Unreal-4-Demo
erinnern.
Klettert da jetzt nicht auch gleich jemand?
Ne, das war wieder was anderes.
Das ist der Typ auf dem Thron, genau.
Na, sieben Jahre
ist ja heutzutage
hardware-technisch
nicht mehr das, wie es vor
sieben Jahre, vor sieben Jahren war.
Also es hat sich schon
einiges getan, die letzten sieben Jahre,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, wie die sieben Jahre davor.
Aber man erkennt das schon.
Patrick, das ist doch wurscht.
Selbst, selbst, wenn sich das,
wenn sich das weiterentwickelt auf den CPUs.
Ähm,
du kannst heute ohne Probleme noch mit
einem Rechner, der vier, fünf Jahre alt ist,
halbwegs spielen und
probier das die sieben Jahre
davor mal aus.
Fand die Fünfer auch besser.
Das Big Brain Chat heute wieder am Start.
Wollen wir uns noch die Dreier,
wollen wir uns noch die Dreier angucken, dann?
Da hat sich noch mehr getan.
Und ich, ich, ich, ich sag euch, Leute,
ihr findet wahrscheinlich die Fünfer auch besser als die Dreier.
Aber der Dreier-Trailer ist der beste.
Damals hat man richtig, boah, die ganzen Partikel und sonst was.
Da hat sich schon, da hat sich schon einiges getan.
Das ist für die PS4.
Aber der Trailer ist für alle gleich.
MonkaS.
So, aber der, der
Dreier-Trailer ist der beste.
Ich mein, das ist ein Riesenunterschied,
wie es aussieht, ja.
Aber der Trailer, der Trailer von, von der
Unreal-3-Engine war am besten bisher.
Mal gucken, ob wir das in ordentlicher Auflösung
irgendwie, irgendwie finden.
Ja.
Das ist der beste Trailer, find ich, von denen.
Denkt dran,
das sind die Games, also
Unreal 3 war ja auf PS3 und Xbox 360.
Ähm,
die Engine schlechthin, ne, da waren ja
irgendwie
gefühlt
60% der Games waren Unreal 3.
Wobei das hier garantiert nicht auf der Xbox
gelaufen ist.
Äh, Unreal 3
kam, was weiß ich, vor 10 Jahren oder so.
Aber der Trailer ist am besten.
Was auch immer
er da macht.
Warum auch immer er an der Kette geschweißt hat.
Bam.
In your face.
Ja.
Okay, Leute.
Welchen Trailer fandet ihr am besten?
Nicht grafisch, sondern rein von der Aufmachung her.
Fünf?
Sechs? Ah, excellent.
Also, also eins ist natürlich
auch nicht, nicht verkehrt, ja.
Ist natürlich
auch nicht schlecht.
Dass fünf echtes Gameplay ist, ist cool.
Ja, das stimmt. Also rein aber von der,
von der, von der Aufmachung her, wie das
geschnitten ist und wie das gemacht wird, finde ich den Dreier
immer noch am besten.
Holy shit, was war das denn? Unreal 1.
Unreal Engine 1.
Ich glaube, das ist auch das erste Mal, dass man so wirklich
den, den Engine Trailer hatte.
Den Gameplay Engine Trailers. Ansonsten haben die halt immer
einen Trailer gemacht in Form von halt so einem Filmchen,
was angeblich halt in Echtzeit gelaufen ist.
Hast du die Unreal Demo auf der, ja, haben wir uns gerade
angeguckt.
Moment, was? Es gibt, es gibt Telekom Unterwäsche.
Ist das safe aufzumachen?
Ja, was jetzt? Was ist das?
Wenn ich das Häkchen wegmache, ist das Häkchen
immer noch da.
Gebated. Guck dir das mal an.
Scammed. Scammed.
Ja, ist mir doch vollkommen egal.
Weiter.
Love Magenta Connected
Underwear.
Oh man.
For men, for women, for kids.
Oh Gott, jetzt wird es aber, jetzt wird es aber gefährlich,
Telekom, hier.
Love Magenta,
Connected Underwear entwickelt.
Die intelligente Unterwäsche,
die das Smartphone vorübergehend zum Schweigen bringt.
Ah, okay.
Das heißt, wenn sich zwei Leute,
die diese Unterwäsche tragen, nähern
oder was, und dann, dann schaltet
er das Smartphone ab.
Bluetooth-Funktion.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Das haben wir uns doch schon mal angeguckt.
Kann man auf der Seite HTTPS-Zertifikate
verschanken?
Krelaks, ich habe keine Ahnung, was du meinst.
Also, was bekommt man?
Eine Love Magenta Stofftasche mit
Kordelzug, aha.
Mit Magenta-DNA, hoffe ich.
Unterhosen.
Herren-Boxer-Shorts.
Ein Damen-Slip.
Hüftige Passform.
Zwei Love-Chips.
Was ein Schwachsinn.
Auf Lager.
Es hätte mich auch gewundert, wenn das ausverkauft wäre.
Max will nur den Damen-Slip.
Ähm, richtig.
Das mache ich dann wieder.
Typ auf dem einen Foto.
Er hat das als Corona-Maske,
oder als Atemschutzmaske verwendet.
Haben wir tatsächlich dem Kumpel zum Geburtstag geschenkt,
sagt der Blobsrusher.
Exzellent.
Wie geht's Chico?
Ja, was die gerade treibt, weiß ich,
aber der geht's gut.
Chico geht's gut.
Chico, glaube mit K,
zumindest guckt sie kritisch.
Auf dem Foto.
Ja, was es nicht alles gibt.
Telekom-Unterwäsche.
Interessant.
Ja, haben wir geguckt.
Jetzt werde ich wieder gebetet, dass mein Mikro angeblich aus ist.
Das hatten wir schon.
Wünschst du dir, dass Mehrarbeitgeber nach der Krise auf dem Zug bleiben mit Homeoffice?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ähm, ich glaube, dass das passieren wird, ja.
Es ist vollkommen egal, ob ich mir das wünsche oder nicht.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass das passieren wird.
Gehe ich von aus, ja.
Zumal ja auch viele Unternehmen jetzt erst angefangen haben,
quasi, dass sie sich nicht mehr auf die Karte stellen.
Quasi, digitale Infrastruktur bereitzustellen, dass es überhaupt möglich ist.
Der Chat wieder.
Low-Brain-Chat gerade.
Ja, aber es wäre auf jeden Fall cool, wenn sich das mehr durchsetzt.
Also, wie gesagt, ich gehe da fest von aus.
Zumal es ja auch noch eine Weile dauern wird, bis das so wieder alles,
falls überhaupt, das mal jemals wieder normal wird.
Keine Prime-Subs, Chat bleibt dumm.
Sieht heute wirklich so aus, ja.
Heute ist mal Abwechslung.
Abwechslungsweise kein High-IQ-Chat da.
Heute ist wirklich...
Ich habe noch nicht mal ein Emote dafür.
Weil normalerweise ist der Chat...
Der Chat ist normalerweise immer schon ziemlich Big-Brain.
Aber heute weiß ich nicht, was mit dem Chat los ist.
David Tree sagt, bei mir bleibt Homeoffice so lange,
bis der Mindestabstand nicht mehr benötigt wird.
Bei uns ist auch noch Homeoffice angesagt.
Liegt an 5G.
Oh, stimmt.
5G-Ausbau geht ja immer weiter.
Und an Bill Gates.
5G und Bill Gates.
Ist bestimmt für meinen Twitch-Chat verantwortlich.
Gehe ich auch von aus.
Ich hatte ja schon immer den Eindruck, dass mit dem Chat was nicht stimmt.
Ah, okay.
Der Flur ist nicht mal 1,5 Meter breit.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es jetzt so,
wir kriegen Masken gestellt von der Firma.
Wir haben allerdings unsere Masken,
erst eine Woche später bekommen, als gedacht.
Weil, das ist jetzt kein Witz,
weil es normale Masken nicht getan haben.
Wir mussten uns erst Masken mit unserem Firmenlogo draufdrucken lassen.
Weil immer.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt quasi ein paar Kisten mit Masken,
wo das Firmenlogo drauf ist.
Ganz wichtig.
Man braucht unbedingt Atemschutzmasken mit Firmenlogo.
Wenigstens FFP2.
Frag keinen.
Kein Schimmer.
Also wer ins Büro geht, der kriegt eine Maske gestellt.
Und bei uns ist Pflicht, dass man die Maske an hat,
sobald man seinen Arbeitsplatz bzw. das Büro verlässt.
Also sprich, wenn man auf den Flur geht, aufs Klo, in die Küche,
sonst wo, muss man die Maske anziehen.
Und wer Mittagessen will, der muss sich vorher anmelden.
Und sagen, wann er kommt.
Und dann kann es sich entweder unten hinsetzen oder eben mitnehmen.
Oder Michael, 50 Milliarden.
Man fragt was.
Ich stehe vor einer schwierigen Entscheidung.
Also ich habe zwei Angebote für eine Ausbildung.
Erstens.
Fachkraft für Lagerlogistik, aber bekomme im ersten Ausbildungsjahr schon knapp 1K.
Muss aber tatsächlich arbeiten.
Das soll als Azubi durchaus vorkommen.
Fachinformatiker für Anwendungsentwicklung,
aber da bekomme ich im ersten Jahr das.
Was gefällt dir denn vom Inhalt her besser?
Scheiß mal auf das Geld.
Du kommst mit beidem Gehalt nicht über die Runden.
Was sagt dir denn mehr zu?
Aber generell nicht so nice.
Da bin ich ganz bei dir, ja, aber die meisten Leute werden wahrscheinlich nicht drumherum kommen.
Was gefällt dir denn besser?
Scheiß auf das Geld.
Also du kommst mit einem K im Prinzip genauso weit wie mit 600, nämlich gar nicht.
Ich stelle seit einem Jahr zuhause. Warum soll ich arbeiten?
Ja, dann mach doch nix!
Dann bleib einfach weiter daheim.
1. Als Fachentworter würde mir nach der Ausbildung mehr verdienen als Fachkraft für Lagerlogistik.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ich würde aber von ausgehen.
1. Ich habe einen Marjaro analog zu deiner Einrichtung
Set up.
2. Meine Statusleiste sieht...
Das gucke ich mir garantiert hier nicht im Stream an.
Das gucke ich mir erst mal auf der anderen Seite an.
3. Ah!
den image fond nicht installiert ja du hast den image fond nicht installiert du musst dir
in meinem fall ist es ein emoji fond du musst dir den emoji fond installieren emoji one oder sowas
du musst den image fond installieren joypixels joypixels musst du installieren dann geht dann
geht deine leiste woher kommt der schlechte ruf von java da muss ich dich jetzt muss ich
dich aber fragen meinst du woher der schlechte ruf kommt warum ich immer über java lästere oder
meinst oder hast du das gehört irgendwo also warum ich über java lästere hat eigentlich keinen
tieferen grund außer dass ich gerne über java lästere ich kann es ist liegt nicht daran dass
java irgendwie unbenutzbar und total scheiße wäre java ist ganz okay man kann schon sachen in java
machen
ansonsten kommt es daher dass halt früher viele scheiß java programme gab auch noch aus zeiten
wo es java applets gab falls ich noch irgendeiner über an java applets erinnern kann an anwendungen
die halt ewig laden scheiße aussehen und irgendwie sich einfach crappy anfühlen aber man darf nicht
vergessen dass gerade im finanzsektor die meisten backends in java sind also sprich
wenn ihr auf die seite von eurer bank geht ist die chance dass das dass der java im hintergrund
läuft relativ hoch also kann mit java ohne probleme gescheite sachen machen und außerdem muss man das
trennen da muss java die programmiert sprache trennen von der rande heim an sich weil java
runtime wenn man eine ordentliche sprache nimmt ist sicherlich ganz gut ich weiß nicht wieso der
direkte vergleich aussehen würde jvm versus jth вполне möglich sei Purdue vorạten beraber wo man
würde JVM vs. .NET Core, keine Ahnung, dafür mache ich zu wenig mit Java, aber ich denke mal so viel
schlechter oder besser, wie auch immer, werden da beide Seiten, beide Seiten werden sich wahrscheinlich
nicht viel nehmen. Alte HP-Switches mit Java-Applet sind das Schlimmste? Ja, mein Management-Interface
hier auf der Serverkiste ist noch ein Java-Applet. Ganz abartig. Warum Java? Wäre da C++ nicht
leistungsfähiger? Ja, doch, wäre es. Schöner wäre es nicht. Also, wenn was noch hässlicher als Java ist,
dann ist es C++, aber du findest einfach deutlich mehr Programmierer, die verstehen, oder zumindest
nicht so viel Scheiße bauen können, für Java als für C++. Und wenn die Komplexität steigt, würde ich sagen,
hat Java trotzdem noch einen Vorteil gegenüber C++. Gerade im Bereich, wenn es sicher sein soll, oder
zumindest...
schwerer zu exploiten, wenn es um Finanzgeschichten geht. Also, du kannst ja quasi in Java keine
Overflows im eigentlichen Sinne produzieren. In C++ ist das easy. Aber ich denke, weil der größte
Faktor ist, dass eben Java im Finanzsektor etabliert ist, und dass du halt recht einfach Java-Programmierer
findest, wohingegen fähige C++-Programmierer ist deutlich schwieriger. Willst du aus dem
Programmierer-Programmierer-Programmierer-Programmierer-Programmierer-Programmierer-Programmierer
herausfinden, wie du das machst, dann kannst du ja auch mal diese
Navy-Punk der Nahe die du dir im Buch machen kannst.
Und, ich meine, in C++, da ist ja auch schon die gewünschte
Stabilität drin, wenn du dein Pursuitspot einmachst.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt die ganz gute Frage.
Ja, ich denke mal, ein remember, was das alles bedeutet, war...
W Потом haben wir ja gesagt, dass
wir jetzt in der Doing-Karte, im Beispiel, ne.
Ja, also, da haben wir nämlich schon noch ganz schön viel gemacht.
Wir haben das ja schon hatten we crossing.
dazu kommt noch ein bisschen YouTube,
bisschen RefLink, bisschen Twitch
und nachdem ich halt auch jemand bin, der kaum
Geld ausgibt,
wird es auch gerade nur mehr.
Aber man weiß nie, wofür man es mal braucht.
Also ich
mache das Gegenteil davon.
Ich kaufe
mir einfach immer, wenn ich was haben will,
kaufe ich es mir und ansonsten gebe ich kaum Geld aus.
Hast du einen Bachelor gemacht? Ne.
Oh fuck, jetzt habe ich was gelöscht.
Was denn?
Hast du große Ziele im Leben? Ja, ich
will mal
mehr Abos auf YouTube.
Ich will mal
300.000 Abos auf YouTube schaffen.
Dazu müsste ich aber Videos machen.
Fährst du gerne in den Urlaub?
Ich bin früher gerne in den Urlaub gefahren.
Ich bin auch früher relativ
viel geflogen in den Urlaub.
Aber ich glaube
die letzten 10 Jahre oder so schon
war ich
bis auf
ein paar
kleinere Ausflüge
nicht mehr lange weg.
Fliegen in 2020? Ja, ich meine ja nicht gerade
jetzt
während den ganzen Corona-Geschichten.
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Kann sein. Kann sein, dass wir damit
auch werben. Aber die ganzen Werbesprüche
kannst du eh vergessen. Ich meine, was soll das denn
heißen? 100 Virenscanner und
150 Firewalls. Was soll
uns das überhaupt sagen?
Ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, Knärbär. Kann man machen.
Man weiß aber nicht, ob das gerade so
die gute Idee ist.
Das ist halt so typischer Marketing-Bullshit.
Circa 100 Virenscanner, 150
Firewalls. Also ich bezweifle, dass
es 100 Virenscanner
irgendwie sicherer machen als
nur eine Handvoll.
Und wenn der Traffic
wirklich durch 150 Firewalls
durch muss,
dann frage ich mich, was die für eine Architektur haben.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich mehr
Videos mache. Ich habe gesagt,
ich verspreche erst gar nicht, dass ich mehr Videos
mache. Keine Prime-Subs.
Chat bleibt dumm. Ja, Low-Brain-Chat
heute. Any Primers?
Der Plopsrascher
schreibt,
Alter, habe heute
meinen ersten richtigen Job bekommen. Danke dafür.
Das ist schön, wenn das will. Falls ich damit
was zu tun habe. Wahrscheinlich liegt es erst einmal
hauptsächlich an dir, dass du die überzeugt hast.
Habe mich damals von
deinen Videos inspirieren lassen,
was mit Informatik zu machen.
Sobald erstes Geld kommt,
gibt es Spende.
Kannst ein paar Subs giften.
Excellent. Dann ist der Chat auch nicht so
Low-Brain. Dann ist endlich wieder High-IQ-Chat
angesagt.
Oh, Chuck690, 10 Monate in Folge.
Massive Subscription.
Es geht aufwärts, Chat.
Ich glaube, der Chat
muss nicht dumm ins Bett gehen heute Abend.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Wie High-IQ bin ich?
Du bist erst ein Monate Abonnent.
Du bist noch nicht High-IQ.
Das kommt noch.
Das braucht...
Das braucht seine Zeit.
Aber du musst dabei bleiben.
Sonst wird das nie was.
Also, Chat. Also,
wenn die Subscription-Monate
High-IQ wären, dann wären wir alle
auf dem Stand von irgendeinem
Nordseekrebs.
Das geht ja nicht über 12 Monate
drüber.
Oder 10 Monate. 10 Monate, glaube ich.
Das ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
so ein Nordseekrebs.
Was ist das für ein Sorgen?
Ist das Luigi's?
Luigi's Mansion? Nee.
Das neue Super Mario.
Du wirst nicht gehasst vom Chat.
Der Chat kann sowas gar nicht.
Das ist Support auf Vodafone.
Kunden-Support auf Vodafone-Niveau.
Selbst alle Beauty-YouTuber
auf YouTube zusammen haben mehr.
Warum streamst du eigentlich in 48 FPS?
Ja, die Frage kommt öfters.
Es liegt einfach daran,
weil 48 FPS
flüssiger sind als 30.
Allerdings
für das einzelne Bild mehr von der
Bitrate übrig bleibt wie bei 60.
Also sieht besser aus.
Und flüssiger.
Das ist quasi das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Flüssiger und besser.
Ähm.
Was schreibt er hier?
Ich rege mich täglich
über die Leute auf, die nicht am Ball bleiben.
Die sind dann meistens auch noch sehr laut.
Oh ja, da gibt es viele von.
Die würden am liebsten noch mit
.NET 3.5 entwickeln.
Nur nicht immer.
Nicht mal 4, sondern wenn schon 3.5.
Und .NET Core
ist böse, weil neu.
Ja, hast du in allen Bereichen.
Ähm.
Jetzt mal unabhängig von .NET.
Bei uns gibt es auch Leute, wo ich mich frage,
ob die
die letzten,
keine Ahnung, die letzten 5 Jahre irgendwie geschlafen haben.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel
noch nicht mal erklären können,
was so der grob der Unterschied ist
zwischen einem Container und einer VM.
Oder man ist Experte für E-Mail-Systeme,
aber kriegt kein SMTP richtig konfiguriert.
Oder was haben wir?
Ach, wir haben so viele,
wir haben so viele Experten,
in Anführungsstriche.
Das ist ja eh so ein Thema.
Wenn ich damit anfange,
höre ich gar nicht mehr auf.
Wir haben so viele Experten,
wo ich mich frage,
in was die Experten sind.
Allerdings höchstwahrscheinlich nicht
in dem, wofür man sie eingekauft hat.
Captain Peng schreibt,
ich habe jetzt gar nicht in den Chat geguckt,
ich habe die ganze Zeit nur in mein Tool geguckt,
schreibt,
ich studiere Informatik
und muss mich langsam entscheiden,
in welche Richtung ich mich orientieren will.
Datenverarbeitung,
aka Big Data
und Webentwicklung
oder Spiele und Spiele-Design
und Spiele-Programmierung.
Da kann ich dir nicht helfen.
Da kann ich die Entscheidung,
kann ich dir glaube ich,
nichts Gutes dazu raten.
Also wenn ihr,
also vorausgesetzt,
dir gefällt beides gleich gut.
Weil das,
was du im Studium da lernst,
ist jetzt ja nicht unbedingt das,
was du später 100%ig machen wirst.
Keine Ahnung.
Da kann ich wirklich nichts zu sagen.
Was hältst du von MacBooks?
Ich finde,
ich finde,
die meiste Apple-Hardware eigentlich ganz gut,
allerdings viel zu teuer
und auch viel zu eingeschränkt.
Ich würde auch mit macOS nicht klarkommen
als Main-Betriebssystem.
Wenn ich von Windows weg könnte,
würde ich Linux verwenden,
allerdings kann ich von Windows nicht weg,
also kann ich auch kein Mac,
verwenden.
Und Windows auf Mac installieren,
kann ich mir auch gleich
irgendwas anderes zusammenbauen.
Habe ich mir auch,
habe ich mir vorgenommen,
ja, dass wir in nächster Zeit
auch ein bisschen Git-Magic zusammen machen.
Piss dich,
Alter.
Das ist aus irgendeiner dummen RTL-Sendung,
wenn ich es,
wenn ich es auch zusammenkriege.
Piss dich,
Alde.
Ist das,
ist das das hier?
Nee.
Doch.
Wo, wo, wo sagt er Piss dich, Alde?
Piss dich, Alde.
Ah, genau.
Das ist so dummer.
Piss dich, Alde.
Das können wir,
das können wir echt hinzufügen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, erst mal runterladen.
Ah, erst mal fünfmal hier Verzeichnis wechseln.
YouTube DL
und dann als,
als welches Format müssen wir das runterladen?
Als hier,
M4A, meinetwegen.
Nee.
140.
Halbwegs guter Quali runterladen.
So.
Und jetzt FFM-Pack.
Input Piss dich, Alde, Output Piss dich, Waff, Explorer, Piss dich, Piss dich, Waff.
Ja, da ist es doch.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Perfekt.
So.
Dann machen wir das mal hier rein.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Ja, funktioniert.
Sehr gut.
So langsam, aber sicher haben wir die Essentials haben wir drin.
Ja.
YouTube DL funktioniert bei dir oft nicht.
Du musst,
bei mir macht der,
also ich weiß, es ist immer eine doofe Antwort,
so nach dem Motto, ja, ich habe keine Probleme,
aber ich habe, glaube ich, noch nicht ein Video nicht runterladen können mit YouTube DL.
Einfach mal,
einfach mal updaten.
Das ist immer so, wenn du eine alte Version hast,
backt das öfters rum, aber
das ist ein Programm, was erstaunlich wenig Probleme macht.
Hast du auf Rocket Beans gesehen,
die machen eine Sendung, wo sie programmieren für ein,
nee, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Zeig mal, wo ist das?
Wo ist das, das da?
Wo ist der Editor?
Wo ist der?
Ich muss, ich muss den Editor sehen hier.
Wie ist Code?
Okay, oh, Big, gut, jeder fängt mal so an.
Wahnsinn, das kriegt man aber auch nach dem ersten Tutorial gebacken.
Das war's.
Gibt's da noch mehr?
Seine Playlist zu also seit über 14 Tagen keine.
Z.
Ah, doch, das ist vor zwei Tagen.
Okay, was machen sie sonst noch so?
Ah, Programmiergrill.
Jetzt werden ein bisschen JavaScript-Funktionen gemacht, okay.
Was ich ja, was ich ja schon wieder
ein bisschen, ein bisschen cringe,
cringe ich finde ist,
man sollte den Leuten gar nicht beibringen,
deutsche Variablen-Namen zu verwenden.
Man sollte gleich sagen,
nennen den Kram,
ordentlich.
Und die korrekte Variante in JavaScript
wäre an der Stelle
sogar Kebab-Case.
Also zweite Minuszahl.
Ja, und das heißt wirklich Kebab-Case.
Wobei, bei Variablen-Namen bin ich mir gar nicht sicher.
Variablen, Variablen in JavaScript auch Kebab?
Kein, ach, keine Ahnung.
Meine Variablen-Namen sind eh viel besser.
Sowas wie Temp
oder I
oder Blubb.
Äh, ich mein ja Bindestrich.
Hab ich Underscore gesagt?
Ich mein Bindestrich.
Also ihr kennt meine Variablen-Namen,
die sind eindeutig, äh,
superior.
Die sind excellent.
Die machen,
ne, die machen kein Kalk,
die rechnen Sachen zusammen.
Aber wenn die in dem Tempo weitermachen wollen,
kommt, dauert das ganz schön lang,
bis da was ordentliches rauskommt am Ende.
Ich bin eine Zeichenkette.
Massive.
Let ist aktiviert, gleich true.
Das ist false?
Äh, was?
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob's es den Leuten gleich ordentlich zeigen.
Oder ob's, oder wie sie es if schreiben.
Falls sie überhaupt ein if machen.
Ähm, weil die meisten Noobs,
die meisten Noobs schreiben,
if ist aktiviert, gleich, gleich true.
Das ist auch im Kopf erstmal,
irgendwie das Logische, ja?
Das kann man schon zeigen,
dass man das so schreiben kann,
aber danach sollte man denen auch gleich zeigen,
dass man das gleich, gleich true einfach weglässt.
Weil, es kommt das Gleiche raus.
Warum ist das denn kein Const?
Ja, man kann's ja auch gleich übertreiben, äh.
Wann, wann kommt das if?
Gibt es irgendeinen Overflow?
Nee, oder?
Ach, JavaScript.
Äh,
äh,
ah!
Okay, was?
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
was da rauskommt.
If zweite gleich, gleich null.
Okay.
Ah ja, gut.
Wow! Oh, meine Augen!
Meine Augen!
Warum denn in Notepad?
Nee, das ist gar kein Notepad.
Ist das Notepad++?
Der Notepad 2 Mod ist das.
Weißt du gar nicht, dass das existiert?
Oh, jetzt wird erstmal Node.js installiert.
Ah, die Verbindung ist abgebrochen.
Okay.
Deutschland und Internet.
Magst du Notepad++ nicht?
Doch, das ist okay, das kann man verwenden.
Wenn man was braucht,
was wirklich schnell startet
und man nicht auf VSCode warten kann.
Ja, aber ich find's gut, dass die sowas machen.
Die haben ja eine gewisse Reichweite.
Ich find's immer schön, wenn
mehr Leute sich für das Thema interessieren.
Unterm Strich
kann's ja auch nur mir zugute kommen.
Dann schlagen vielleicht ein paar mehr Leute
bei mir im Stream auf
und werden Teil des...
Was aber sehr unwahrscheinlich ist,
dass einer von dem Rocket Beans Video
bei mir jetzt auf Twitch aufschlägt.
Außerdem machen wir ja gar kein Programmierzeug.
Was magst du an Notepad++ nicht?
Gar nix.
Achso, die hab ich ja grad schon beantwortet.
Hast du die Clipboard History an?
Nein, hab ich nicht an.
Doch.
Mehr gibt's nicht.
Ich hab die Clipboard History an.
Hörst du spezielle Musik beim Programmieren?
Ja, mach ich.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Also, ich hab da so zwei
zwei
Betriebsmodi.
Nennen wir's
mal so.
Ich hab einmal die Sache,
wo ich mich sehr auf
einzelne
Probleme konzentrieren
muss, die kompliziert sind.
Dann mach ich meistens
entweder sowas
hier an.
Wartet mal. Irgendwie sowas da.
Collection Mix 2019
oder sowas. Sowas hier.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz entspannend.
Sowas.
Manchmal mach ich auch irgendwelche Klassik an.
Das ist aber,
wenn ich mich auf einzelne Sachen konzentrieren muss
und die kompliziert sind.
Dann mach ich meistens so an. Und wenn ich
mal so im generellen Architektur-Mode
bin,
wo ich mir so Gedanken mach.
Was braucht man da vielleicht für
Klassen? Welche Technik nimmt man da?
Da hab ich entweder gar nichts an
oder
Zeugs, was
ich sonst auch hör.
Lautsprecher oder immer Kopfhörer?
Eigentlich immer Kopfhörer.
Deswegen, das ist auch der Moment,
wo ich da die super bequemen Kopfhörer
anziehe, die ich euch letztens mal gezeigt hab.
Und ich dachte schon,
Max hört Heavy Metal beim Programmieren.
Bei so normalen Architektursachen
oder wo ich einfach nur ein bisschen nachdenke
und gucke, wie man was machen könnte,
da läuft das normale Zeug, was ich sonst so höre.
Also das kann dann alles Mögliche sein.
Das kann dann
bis zu dem hier gehen.
Das kann dann bis zu dem hier gehen.
Any bangers?
Aber das ist nicht
die richtige Programmiermusik.
Das ist übelst geil, dass man
Einer der Besten, ey.
Das ist das Richtige,
um SQL zu programmieren, Leute.
Beste,
das ist das Beste für Cobol.
Gerade mit dem
TAC programmiert.
Nee, das kannst du nicht
im TAC programmieren.
Ja, für SQL ist das sicherlich auch sehr nice.
Ich mein,
für DBAs, für Daten,
für Datenbank-Admins
der beste Titel schlechthin, oder?
Ich hoffe,
das nimmt kein Datenbank-Admin ernst hier.
Das ist vorbei.
Flash
komplett.
DD, Def 0,
SDA,
Job Table, genau, alles weg.
Ich mein, für so esoterische
Sprachen wie Brainfuck wär's
vielleicht auch nicht schlecht.
Hab ich schon mal gesagt, dass
die Musik echt gut ist?
Es ist nicht jedermanns Sache, aber
wenn man auf so Wikinger-Zeug steht,
ist das einer der besten Songs überhaupt.
Aber die meisten stehen ja nicht
auf Wikinger-Sachen und solche Dinger.
Die meisten
hören sich lieber, keine Ahnung,
ApoRed an oder so.
Oder was auch immer da gerade angesagt ist.
Der Refrain
ist halt super, super nice.
Die würd ich mir auch mal live angucken.
Annie Bangers
Äh, äh,
Muri, oh du Scheiße, kann ich aussprechen.
MuriMC
war der 75.
oder was auch immer. Die haben viele geile Sachen.
NC Ferrum
ist auch geil, aber eher die älteren Sachen.
Mit dem alten Sänger, frag mich nicht, wie der heißt.
Yari irgendwas.
Die findest du in der Extremo, find ich auch
paar Sachen gut. Nicht alles.
Echt, live gesehen
enttäuschen? Äh, lass mich mal
raten. Ich rate mal,
was dich enttäuscht hat.
Du kannst mal sagen, ob das stimmt.
Ich vermute mal, dass man, ich mein,
hier verstehst du noch halbwegs was.
Ich denke mal, dass man
live
Vocal-mäßig,
Gesang-mäßig nichts
checkt und es auch nicht
irgendwie harmonisch dazu passt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da Gesang gut
hinkommt live.
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es ein bisschen problematisch ist.
Ansonsten,
was hat dir denn nicht gefallen?
Wacken fällt aus.
Ja, stimmt.
Die Gamescom fällt auch aus.
Bei dem Genre kommt's auf Gesang an. Ja.
So blöd's klingt, ja.
Was hältst du von Ailstorm?
Oh, das sind die Pirates.
Äh, ja, die haben auch
paar coole Sachen.
Aber da hab ich nichts Neueres
gehört
bisher von denen.
Also, was die so in den letzten Jahren gemacht haben, keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Gamescom findet digital statt.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wenn wir in Deutschland
eine Messe rein digital ausrichten wollen.
Da hab ich ja so meine
Bedenken.
Dass das gut funktioniert.
Wir sind ja, was digital angeht,
voll vorne mit dabei immer.
Von unten betrachtet.
Das erste, was passieren wird, ist, wenn die Gamescom
der Gamescom-Stream online geht,
erstmal MonkaSmoke geht erstmal nicht mehr.
Genau, erstmal der Server weg.
So, das haben wir,
das haben wir jetzt ausführlich beantwortet.
Kennst du dich mit Kabelnetzen aus?
Nein. Keine Ahnung.
Merkelwave.
Zum Teufel ist Merkelwave.
Ne.
Wat?
Das ist irgendein Trollversuch, den ich nicht checke.
Alles auf Masterforce.
Ne, das ist nicht, was ich unter Gitmagic verstehen würde.
Oh, jetzt ist hier
BigBrainTime vom Flo690 angesagt.
Warum steht da so viel
KW im Chat, wobei da nur einmal KW vorkommt?
Was hältst du
von Microsoft Surface?
Ähm.
Hm.
Find ich gut.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit ein paar Surface.
Äh, äh, wie heißen die?
Books, Tablets.
Und auch diese
Surface-Bildschirme.
Die sind wirklich nice.
Sag nichts Böses, dann sind wir sauer.
Ne, find ich gut.
Dein Professor nennt seine
Getter Setzer und Geber.
Oh, exquisit.
Der mag alles auf Deutsch.
Setzer und Geber.
Ja, warum? Warum Geber und nicht
Holer? Aber das
ist, ja, mein, wenn er
da drauf steht.
Habe neulich in Production Code
tatsächlich die Variante Temp
und danach die Variante TempTemp verwendet.
Ich mach das
laufend, ey.
Auch wenn es nicht schön aussieht.
Manchmal, wenn du in bestehende Sachen
was reinquetschen musst.
Warum nicht?
Also TempTemp verwendet,
TempTemp kommt selten vor.
Aber ich, bei mir heißt es meistens so.
Die erste Variable ist TMP
und dann habe ich noch ne Temp und eventuell noch ne Blub.
So.
Ich glaube das sind so meine, vielleicht noch I.
I ist auch noch dabei.
Ich glaube diese Kombi sind meine, ähm,
ähm,
meist verwendeten Variablen Namen.
TMP, Temp, Blub und I.
Ne, E verwende ich nicht.
Als, nach I kommt immer J.
Ah, Captain Peng,
wir verstehen uns.
Ja, K, K, ich habe selten so,
so nested Schleifen, dass ich
drei, drei Variablen für brauche.
Das sind so meine meist benutzten
Variablen.
Und, und mittlerweile ist das schlimme, meine Test
Strings ist oftmals der da.
Jetzt kein Witz.
Wenn ihr es bei uns sehen könntet, es gibt
ein paar Scripts und ein paar Sachen
wo, wo als, als Default
Text KEKW drinsteht.
KEKW, sorry.
KEK, doppeltes
U. Aber nur halt
Default und danach kommt was anderes rein.
Also wenn ihr wissen wollt,
ob ihr in der gleichen Firma arbeitet wie ich,
durchgabt mal eure Git Repos nach KEKW.
Aber bitte nicht auf der Arbeit
nutzen, das kommt nie durch ein Code Review.
Naja.
Es hat
manchmal schon seinen Vorteil, wenn man derjenige
ist, der Code Reviews macht.
Ne, aber in dem Code, der in dem
unsere größeren Repos drin ist,
da versuche ich auch nicht
Temp, Temp, Plup und
I und Zeug zu verwenden und auch kein
KEKW. Das ist bei kleineren
Sachen.
Die vielleicht mal bei dir
lokal oder in irgendeinem privaten Repo
eingecheckt sind.
Oder auf irgendwelchen Servern rumfliegen.
Oh ne.
Skate702 programmiert
gerade eine LED Steuerung im Stream.
Äh.
Okay.
Excellent.
Statt KEKW einfach AI
verwenden. Das ist natürlich eine Top
Idee.
Ähm. Ja.
Ihr wisst Leute, es ist 22 Uhr.
Wir werden jetzt Schluss machen.
Skate702.
Ich kenne ihn gar nicht. Wer ist das denn?
Warte mal.
Zeig mal.
Was programmiert denn? LED Steuerung.
Minecraft Modding Skaten?
Skaten. Das hätte ich bei dem Namen auch
irgendwo. Den, doch.
Den habe ich schon mal auf Twitter gesehen, glaube.
Ähm. Ansonsten, ansonsten kenne ich ihn nicht.
Aber ich kenne
eh kaum einen in YouTube und Twitch
Deutschland.
Was macht der denn sonst so? Coding Stream.
Excellent.
Minecraft.
Minecraft?
Das bedeutet ja Java.
War der nicht damals
mit dir auch bei Nvidia?
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Vielleicht.
Java. Oh ne.
Please.
Wie komme ich jetzt auf den Stream zurück?
Ne, jetzt spielt er GTA.
Coding Stream vorbei.
Okay. Ne, dann,
dann nicht.
Dann, dann hosten wir nicht.
Ist Minecraft mittlerweile nicht mehr Java?
Kommt drauf an, welche Edition.
Die normale Java Version und die, die auch noch
90% der Leute spielen, die, die
auf Multiplayer-Servern unterwegs sind,
ist Java.
Gibt es ein Ahi-Java
was ein Ahi-Java
Emote?
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Da müssten wir ihm
hier irgendeine Kaffeetasse noch
draufsetzen oder so.
Igitt Emote. Leute, ich habe eine riesig lange Liste
mit Emotes. Ich müsste halt mal einen Designer
endlich, endlich beauftragen
Emotes zu machen.
Und das Problem bei mir ist, wenn ich
mit sowas anfange, ich bin extrem pingelig.
Ja? Also ich bin,
ich bin wirklich pingelig, was das angeht.
Wenn irgendjemand für mich Emotes macht,
wenn die nicht 100%ig zünden
bei mir, nehme ich die nicht.
Ich bin da wirklich unglaublich
pingelig. Bin ich bei meinen Sachen auch
meistens.
Man kann es halt,
das ist halt so eine subjektive Sache.
Also sprich,
da gibt's ja nix, wo man sagen kann,
ja, dieses Emote passt perfekt.
Das muss ich sagen.
So allgemein kann man das nicht sagen.
Bei Fiverr gibt's ein paar gute
Designer. Ja stimmt, ich sag doch,
es ist überhaupt kein Problem, welche
zu finden, denke ich.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal auf Twitter fragen.
Weil
bei Fiverr hast du immer ewig rumdiskutiere.
Am besten
wäre es, ohne Mist,
am besten wäre es, wenn ich auf
auf Twitter ein paar gute
empfohlen kriege, dann macht man
mit denen halt mal was aus, keine Ahnung,
200€.
Für, was weiß ich,
15, 10,
ich weiß nicht, wie da die Preise sind, für 10 Emotes.
Aber dann halt
so, dass ich am Ende sage,
ja, die zünden und sind genau die,
die ich mir vorstellen
würde.
Ich hab ja da keine Schmerzen für,
auch ein bisschen Kohle auszugeben.
Ich mein, der Chat,
es muss sich ja lohnen zu Subscribern.
Lohnt sich ja aktuell gar nicht.
Zumindest nicht für Emotes.
Ich hab noch 20 Slots,
glaube, frei.
20 Emote-Slots,
die ich noch reinhauen kann.
Willst du es nicht für Reichweite holen?
Was meinst du?
Es wäre auf jeden Fall sinnvoll,
das zu holen.
Also, ich sollte mir Emotes holen.
Nee, ich sollte mir, ich sollte mir
auf jeden Fall Emotes holen.
Muss.
Wozu, warum sollte ich 20 Emote-Slots
ungenutzt lassen?
Das mache ich das letzte Jahr auch schon.
Aber es muss ja mal langsam...
Ich frag morgen mal.
Ich mach das echt so.
Ich frag morgen mal auf Twitter,
ob ich
entweder gute Designs
habe als Follower,
aber dann halt auch mit Link auf
bestehende Werke schon.
Oder ob es welche
gibt, die mir welche empfehlen.
Und ich werde auch,
ich werde auch gleich
einen gewissen Geldbetrag
reinschreiben, so nach dem Motto
will
für 200 Euro Emotes kaufen.
Ich glaube,
der Jan ist
kein Emote-Designer.
Der Jan ist Mediengestalter.
Der macht, glaube ich, irgendwelche Webseiten-Designs
und sonst was. Ich glaube nicht, dass der
irgendwie
Illustrator oder so ist.
Geil, Max gibt Kopfgeld aus.
Naja, da muss ich ja
zumindest schon mal lohnen,
dass ich irgendwas Sinnvolles
mit meinem Twitch-Money machen kann.
Easy Money.
Ich weiß nicht, hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung,
was ein fairer,
guter Preis ist?
Was kriegt man?
Was kosten 5 Emotes?
So, dass man sagen kann,
das lohnt sich für jemand, der die macht.
Auch mit ein paar Revisions,
dass was Gutes rauskommt.
Fiverr-Preise.
Keine Ahnung.
Fiverr-Preise sind...
Ich hab doch mal in Inder was aus Spaß
für mich programmieren lassen,
weil ich gucken wollte, was rauskommt.
Erinnert ihr euch noch?
Ich hab doch
11 Leute angeschrieben auf Fiverr,
dass sie das programmieren,
was wir im Stream programmiert haben.
Weil ich gucken wollte, was rauskommt.
Das, was rausgekommen ist,
war komplett für den Arsch
und die Preise, die da standen,
für die wollte keiner was arbeiten.
Süße Tier-Emotes
mit vielen Details sind toll.
Naja, bei der so klein
wie Twitch-Emotes sind,
mit vielen Details ist ja da eh nix.
Ich will irgendwelche Emotes,
die streambezogen sind,
allerdings, die man auch gut
auf Twitch allgemein
verwenden kann.
Mann mit Kohle sucht Frau mit Emote.
So ungefähr, ja.
So ungefähr.
Ich hab ne Liste mit Emote-Ideen, ja.
Ja, sind da auch
paar richtig gute Sachen bei.
Naja, gut.
Ähm.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich werd mich da morgen mal
schlau machen.
Auf
Twitter mal fragen.
Gucken.
So, ich wollte vor 10 Minuten schon abhauen, Leute.
Macht's gut, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Ähm.
Jetzt bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch eins zu sagen.
Bis, äh, die Tage.
Morgen werd ich wahrscheinlich den ganzen Tag
Hardcore Modern Warfare
durchgrinden.
Vielleicht streame ich mal.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das Leute überhaupt
sich angucken wollen,
wie ich quasi, äh,
ein bisschen, äh,
übe.
Weil ich bin ja noch nicht wahnsinnig gut,
wieder, ja.
Ähm.
Weil die meisten Leute, die hier sind, sind eindeutig,
für Technikkrams am Start mittlerweile.
Okay, Leute.
Also, wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Bis denn. Wir sehen uns.
See you.